of all the sickness that we have in the
world and especially the western
countries of all the chronic diseases
we're seeing it's not because they're
eating too much kale like they're not
eating too much fruit like right like
right like they're not eating enough
fruits and vegetables that's 100 sure
all the things they're eating too much
of vegetables are not it right right
right or not so for seeing people who
are not um like having enough conversion
like why not at least start there to see
that sure right are they eating enough
fresh fruits and vegetables i am more
concerned about the absorb absorbability
rate and that's where
that's debatable i know that animal
proteins are 80 to 100
absorbable and then plant proteins are
lower than that but that's where people
argue our plant protein sources
enough to absorb
enough protein and then get enough for
proper
liver nourishment shouldn't we consider
the killing of the animal part of their
suffering because like we i think
there's euphemisms used to make us feel
better about the foods that we eat like
you know um it was ethically killed
ethically hunted and so i feel better
about the the foods that i'm eating but
we would never say that we like
ethically killed like anyone other than
an animal it just feels better
when really that animal didn't want to
die sure you know what i'm saying i
think that we say these things
now because of the of the pushback from
from vegan activists who are like well
this isn't ethical and we're like well
how do we find a solution where there
there is a you know massive group of
people that absolutely believe that they
need that food in their lives and that's
the word question exactly
hey guys welcome to another episode
you're going to love this conversation
my friend corey and i had if you've
followed me for any amount of time you
know that i advocate for and live a
whole foods plant-based vegan lifestyle
my friend corey creates content online
for her career as well and she advocates
for a way of eating which includes
plants and animals like raw dairy organ
meats grass-fed beef and eggs and is
often called the pro-metabolic lifestyle
corey and i have grown to become close
friends over the last year and i even
got to be a birth support for her and
document her v back home birth with her
daughter's story born a few months ago
we naturally connect in many ways and we
get along really organically we also
both really love challenging discussions
so we've privately had many
conversations about nutrition and
they're always fruitful in this episode
we discuss navigating friendships with
opposing views we tackle nutrition where
we align where we disagree and why as
well as ethics and planetary health and
you know this is not like an
all-encompassing full discussion on
everything in nutrition we actually
didn't even get to like one percent of
what we could have talked about this is
more about sharing how we converse when
we disagree on a specific topic and how
we handle it in a peaceful respectful
way this conversation is not even close
to encompassing the whole of our dietary
perspectives so please bear with us as
we amateurs get into the weeds of
science the best that we can and overall
if you're interested in what we've
shared today you can check out our own
content further i love and respect corey
so much so i want to give her mad props
for coming into my space to publicly
have this conversation i think a lot of
people don't realize how difficult it is
to find someone who not only enjoys
civil discourse and challenging
discussions with opposing views but
someone who is also willing to have
these types of discussions publicly
online please share your thoughts in the
comments but be kind and civil and
respectful to both of us involved if it
gets nasty towards either one of us the
chances of this type of episode
happening again lessens it's really
difficult to get these types of
conversations happening and i really
want to do more in the future so please
be kind you can learn more about corey
on her instagram corey malloy or listen
to her own podcast the freely rooted
podcast without further ado let's get
into this episode i hope you enjoy it
alright
thank you so much corey for being here i
am so excited to have this conversation
today and i know that we have
like we really enjoy these conversations
in person but it's a whole other bald
game
doing it publicly so i really appreciate
you coming on the show today yes i am
very excited to be here um you mentioned
it probably like i think two weeks ago
you're like what do i what do you think
about this and i was like
i i feel nervous about that um but let's
talk about it and um yeah i'm just
really excited to be here so i just
appreciate you having me this is such an
honor to be here and talking about this
these topics with you and
just being able to do it in a respectful
way totally i mean that's how our
conversations always go so i just knew
it would be like that here and it would
just be the perfect conversation to have
on here although there's other topics we
could totally talk about too which maybe
we'll do yeah in the future yeah but so
my first question for you is did you
have it sounds like you did have any
reservations coming on here today and
why don't you share with us like what
those are yes um yeah i had a couple i
would say the first which i feel like
you and i actually really agree on is
that food is just one tool in the
toolbox and i didn't want to like
i i think this is a really hyper focused
um topic sometimes like the the vegans
versus like the carnivores you know and
that being like oh this is the reason
you have all your problems and vice
versa um and i just think it's one tool
in the toolbox and that uh so much more
needs to be talked about you know in the
discussion of health but you and i
discuss that all the time and that's why
you're the perfect person to be sitting
here and talking uh with about this
and then the second reservation would i
guess just the idea of you know i'm in
your space your
territory and i've had a
i've had experiences in the past where
um followers of yours have come to my
page whenever you you've like reshared a
story or something that had nothing to
do with food um i know one was like
me telling my birth story
and you had reposted um like one story
slide and i like within a couple hours
had to just block block block and i'm
not like a a blocker i i really i really
really appreciate the way that you are
like this as well of just like not
living in an echo chamber and really um
being able to see different opinions but
yeah the kind the comments were just
horrific and um i was not expecting it i
was really thrown off and i was like am
i just
entering into a space where this is
gonna happen again and but i just don't
think that's that's the case i think
that it's going to be a much different
response
um through the way that we're
approaching it right and we've talked
about this before for anyone who's
listening or watching this about like
how i'm totally in agreement of how
horrific that is and i don't think that
that's helpful nor is that i don't think
that's helpful for the person like not
only not you but it's not helpful for
the person saying speaking in that way
just like um name calling jumping to
conclusions like just to me i find it so
disingenuous and not helpful personally
like just at all and and i think one of
the most important things that i've
written down here that we need to like
address that's really crucial is
understanding people's intentions behind
things so if anyone like came onto your
page obviously i was like so annoyed
when you told me that like earlier like
yeah
really because obviously i mean and you
know that's not the majority of the
people right who are in either of our
realms right of our spaces or let's
we're talking about myspace
specifically um but there's going to be
outliers and there's going to be you
know differences on how people handle
things and i completely disagree with it
i think it's super important to realize
people's intentions and that most people
are doing what they think is best with
the information they have
um
like especially this is so crucial when
navigating conversations like this and
so a lot of people listening i'm sure
tuning in like okay they're really good
friends how do they navigate this which
we'll get into
um
but
again even just like reading this i
think it's super important to like
um
not assume that people who eat or
advocate for eating animals are doing it
for selfish
reasons selfish intent or lack of
empathy
we have to come from a place of trying
to understand why people think the way
that they do and that's what this
conversation is all about
yeah
so okay so something else i really want
to address too is that to talking about
my audience who's listening here that
how vegans respond to this type of
conversation is not even binary at all
like on one of the spectrum there could
be like
ethical vegans who might even be the
types of people that you're talking
about who reach who responded to you in
that way like name calling and stuff
who would be upset that i would even
empathize with someone's like um
feelings and um
logic or desire to thinking that they
need this to be like animal foods to be
healthy and then there's other people on
the other end of the spectrum who might
be plant-based or not plant-based at all
um and thinking like what is the big
deal why are we why are you making this
a big deal like it doesn't matter it's
just food type thing so
that is super important going into the
conversation too that
so many different people are coming in
with different life experiences
different sets of world views and that's
why i think this conversation's so
fascinating
so okay you already covered the type of
messages that you receive oh no no i was
going to ask you this is where we're
going in next okay the type of messages
that you often receive
when people like find out that you have
a lot of vegans in your circle of
friends oh yes um well i think
complete confusion first of all um i i
still get messages every single week
even though i haven't like it's not like
i'm posting that we're friends all the
time you know what i mean um i'll get
messages i'll get emails um a lot of
people very curious but i think just
being i think they're just like truly
confused of just like how would this
work um i've had a few messages going
like do you guys just like argue all day
long and i'm like
what
um can you just imagine we're like
sitting on the beach with all our kids
like surfing and we're just arguing with
each other yes yes and some there are
there are a few times where i actually
reply the messages because i i want to
have an opportunity to be like hey like
this
you can have
relationship with people that you
disagree with like that is the that is
humanity like that is humanity and
that's how you grow and you learn from
each other and how
boring would that be to like live in an
echo chamber where you only you know uh
surround yourself with people that think
exactly like you because honestly i
don't know anybody that thinks exactly
like me i would be by myself totally my
my husband and even we disagree on
anything same here same so i think maybe
people are thinking that because i have
a platform um on health and you have a
platform on health that like the food
part of the health is like all we talk
about and all we think about and it's
just not the case you and i
agree on so much so like an insane
amount of things and we our husbands
have to pry each other away from each
other um whenever yes just like let's go
like let's leave like just five minutes
five minutes i know i'm like i'm coming
i'm like 30 minutes later i'm like oh
yeah oh wait i really need to go yeah
and then and then continue even more so
like ellen and i like can't stop talking
about the things that we are uh equally
passionate about and even the things we
disagree about sometimes it pops up like
hey i was listening to your episode i
found this because i listened to your
podcast episode yes or to your podcast
and i'm like i found this part really
interesting like i totally resonate with
this this part i'm not sure what are
your thoughts on this you know we just
go back back and forth but yes it's true
i think a lot of people assume that like
all we are talking about must be about
what we disagree on and
about food when that just simply is not
the case we're talking about parenting i
don't know we just naturally connect on
so many levels and personality plays a
huge role because something really
interesting is that you could i could
come across someone who is vegan and
have like that feel like there's nothing
in common and have very little like
inclination or desire to like keep a
conversation going or like just don't
naturally gravitate towards that and you
could have the same thing for someone
who lives in the way that you do
and you could have become friends with
someone who has completely different
views on many things
and you naturally just click in so many
ways and that isn't always the case for
a lot of people i think a lot of people
um like struggle
first first there's like this thing
embedded into our modern culture i think
that you need to only be friends with
people who agree with you right but
there's so many other factors on what
makes a good friend and list and i think
like listening to each other's
perspective
which i was actually going to ask you so
what do you think makes a relationship
like ours thrive oh wow um oh with you
and me i think that um first off we have
our brains are like
i feel like made from very similar
matter like i like we'll be talking to
each other and we're like that's exactly
like that's exactly what i was thinking
it's actually insane to me it's very
insane and um i think that that has
played a huge role in how we have
conversations with each with each other
because they're so like entertaining for
us and so
life-giving because we're like having a
conversation with with ourselves but
it's just so it's it's very enjoyable to
have
respectful conversations and also um
both both you and i are big
communicators like communication yes is
so important to both of us in
relationships period and the most
important thing to both of us because
we've we've
found this out about each other
is um honesty uh
and open communication like that being
like the most important thing and so
because we value that in each other we
are a safe place for each other yes and
therefore whatever we disagree on
we're always going to be able to be
honest and be a safe place for each
other um and i think that is
that makes people very um
uncomfortable i think that there's a lot
of people that don't like that aren't
like that and they would rather have
someone like just on their side and
that's what makes them feel safe in a
relationship or like not judging them
and that that's that's what makes people
feel safe and because ellen and i like
um value a lot of the same things i
think it makes conversations so safe
well and also there's the aspect of we
aren't judging each other yes the goal
is how how to best understand each
other's
like why why we think the way that we do
exactly whereas you're right it is
easier and and really fun sometimes you
know and a lot of times to have friends
that like agree with you on these topics
you're really passionate about of course
yes but i i think because we're both
like enneagram eights which i talked
about we talked about the enneagram my
last episode um that plays a role into
like i guess i kind of like thrive on
conversations with controversial ideas
my friend josefa and danielle sent me
this screenshot of like a deep dive into
the enneagram eights and it was like one
of the things was like we'll ask um
uh hard questions and like uncomfortable
questions just to see how people react
to see if they're squirmish like how if
they get squirmish
and i'm like whoa i am like that yes
like i really just i i like to see
people squirm sometimes because it's
it's fun but also also because it's such
a friendly environment and i don't think
people are realizing like how friendly
it is
when when those questions are asked and
the goal of those questions behind the
fun of it is really just to understand
somebody yes and a lot of people don't
have that perspective yes and maybe
their childhood experiences told them
otherwise that if they disagreed with
someone that they got shunned or um if
you stood out like even maybe with your
parents if you if you said something you
disagreed with with your parents if they
shunned you or gave you some kind of
punishment whether that was like um
what's the word like passive aggressive
disrespect or something like that
that shapes how people know how to have
conversations or not because i do have
some friends that really don't enjoy
discussions with differing opinions like
anxiety can can you know start coming up
and then it's not fun it's obviously
only fun if someone really enjoys the
conversation that's probably why we
naturally gravitate toward each other
exactly so you feel like the anxiety is
almost like more of like a trauma
response sometimes maybe or maybe part
of its personality yeah and maybe it's
just harder for like someone like us to
relate to it yeah because of our
personality maybe it's both maybe it has
to do a little bit about personality but
how much of your personality is from
what you were nurtured as exactly i
don't know exactly and i like just to
add one more thing to that thought um i
like that you were talking about um just
the idea of welcoming
questions that are the heart behind it
is to get to know somebody because i
feel like that that alone can be
threatening for people because they
don't want to be they feel vulnerable i
guess um when someone is like really
actually pursuing them and that's the
actual
intent i think somebody can take the
intent as like what do you want to know
like what do you you know like are you
trying to catch me in something or
something like that as opposed to like
oh no i just want to know you i want to
love you like that's that's you and
um so if you're not ready for it you
know like if you're not ready for that
in your life then yeah i could see how
it would make you uncomfortable to have
these kind of conversations yes and i
didn't realize that i was on this like
far extreme end of the spectrum like
when it comes to this experience until
maybe in the last few years as i was
becoming closer with like josepha who
wasn't used to this she's like what are
you doing why are you bringing this up
and i'm like i just don't have a
conversation what's the big deal she's
like no i don't know and i'm like i love
you no matter what you think i'm just
curious like why you think the way that
you do then over time she's like okay i
understand you now and now she really
enjoys that with me and then when we
became like made friends with someone
new had like a girl's night i'm asking a
question and they're like wait what and
cause i was like but that's just the way
she's like she's just waiting yes just
just relax like she likes you exactly
anyways i mean we could go on and on oh
something else i want to say
was um
i think it's probably interesting for
people too because we both are like you
said advocating for different ways of
eating
right
and
i had
said this to you before like when we
were first becoming closer like i've had
i have many friends who aren't vegan i
have friends who used to eat plant-based
that no longer anymore but i've never
had a friend to my recollection who
advocated for like actively advocated
for a way of eating that wasn't vegan
yeah because i've had you know pretty
much most all my friends
i don't know up until maybe in the last
couple years or so would be very like i
know that the way you're eating is like
so healthy i just i don't have it in me
or like i just don't know if i could do
it or like i just don't think like i did
very well that way but i know the way
you guys are eating is so good and your
family's thriving and stuff like that
but then when it came to this it was
like oh like you're like actively
advocating for a different way of eating
so that was like that was a different
space for me but i still like totally
found it compelling and that's why i was
like come over for a girls night let's
like get into this yes and oftentimes we
just don't even have the time to get
really too into it because i think these
types of conversations do require
undivided attention which we don't often
have with all the kids very rare yeah so
if we do find a moment when we're alone
like walking away from somewhere we'll
like dabble but we've only really had
like deep conversations about what we
really disagree on like a couple of
times when we were alone for like a
period of time a significant period of
time so that's to put to rest anyone
confused on how we yes handle yeah just
basically respectful conversation and i
also to add to what you just said i just
really respected the way that you were
honest whenever i had moved here and you
were like and you were like yeah this is
how i felt and i was like oh my gosh
that takes so much um i think humility
to be like this was interesting to me to
navigate like here's somebody advocating
for a different way of eating and it was
just it was just interesting and like i
just thought it was it just took so much
humility for you said which tells you
how um grounded and and confident you
are as a woman and that's somebody
that's something i really respect about
you and that's probably why we got close
together because you're because you're
like a question asker you're like
literally made for podcasting i think
you're so good at questioning everyone
you actually when i first met you i was
like wow you ask a lot of questions
like getting to know like so good at
asking questions you put it on other
people because you want to learn about
them yes so i also think that
maybe you're because it's surprising
that i don't think i really get emails
like that that you get of people being
like why are you friends with someone
who's not being and i don't get emails
like that which is kind of surprising to
me i kind of would imagine it be the
other way around right um since there's
a lot of like conviction within eating
vegan i guess i do get questions of like
do you have friends who are not vegan
but nothing like specifically pertaining
to us that i've noticed but maybe i just
don't see yes like i don't see all my
messages that's for sure um but i think
maybe you're getting
more questions about that because
everyone pretty much knows that there is
like it veganism is like the only diet
that there's like a conviction aspect
that's more than just your health like
exactly not not everybody who eats
plant-based obviously there's people who
just eat plant-based by their health but
people who are vegan and ethical vegans
like there's a conviction morality
behind it
about the animals and so i think they
probably ask you like how do you not
feel judged by people who are vegan
because you're advocating to eat animals
well
like and i think people maybe don't
realize that like
your friends in this space like all of
our friends who are vegan like that's
just not how they operate they aren't
thinking like that towards you they're
if anything's still interested in
hearing your perspective yes and i was
also thinking of at my um mother's
blessing you guys threw like a mother's
blessing for me before i before i gave
birth
and our friend danielle was like i would
even
i would even i would even bring you like
a meal with animal food in it and people
were like what i was like you would i
wouldn't
she's like maybe i wouldn't but like but
that's the love and the rest of the show
yes and i was like i wouldn't do that
i was like i would just bring you like a
pro metabolic vegan like
which
i want to try and make her pro metabolic
wave eating like vegan as yeah like see
if i can do that yes that's totally true
okay so let's get into it then can you
share people who don't know like what
you specifically advocate for like what
is like your way of eating and living
that you that you teach and and tell
people about yeah so essentially my like
philosophy um definitely not original to
me there are many amazing people that
have walked before me that i um have
strived to learn from
but essentially it is all about
optimizing the metabolism and so the
metabolism not to get too heady i'll
keep it like simple it is the function
of your body and so
um your metabolism describes basically
like uh you know if it's describing the
function your body you're describing
detoxification and hormone balance and
um you know cell renewal and
your ability to be resistant to stress
it's because it's the health of
basically your cell and our entire body
is made of cells and so
um to describe this in a way that people
will probably like resonate with i think
it's helpful to describe the opposite of
that and there was this man named
raymond earl and in the 1920s he came
out with this rate of living theory and
his theory is that we have like
a um a max amount of heartbeats in our
body if you can like imagine like a
ticking time bomb to like reach that
last heartbeat and then you die um and
so he came up with the theory that if we
slow down our entire body we are
increasing like
life you know
and longevity but what he is kind of
like missing as far as that picture is
to slow down your body you're slowing
down every cell process of your body and
so you're slowing down um gut motility
and the ability to heal like your wounds
to heal and so everything is slowing
down however there were a lot of health
um crazes and i guess philosophies that
were birthed from that idea and so like
some of them not to
trigger anybody but like cold therapy
intermittent fasting um fat as fuel
instead of glucose as fuel um there were
a lot of popular crazes that came from
that with not realizing that that was
kind of like the the basis of of why
these things came about and a lot of
them are still popular today um
and so it kind of comes back to
basically the opposite of that and there
were
a couple people like dr broda barnes and
dr ray pete who were finding that
metabolism and the function of your body
is basically the root of all dysfunction
because the better that your body is
functioning um the more inline and
imbalanced that it can be and so for
example if your liver detoxification is
slowed down you're not able to detox
estrogen and so you you're like
basically creating estrogen dominance in
your body um and therefore the ratio of
estrogen to progesterone um is off and
so and this can go can go on and on you
guys can probably understand that are
listening what all this would impact but
to optimize the metabolism is basically
just you know studying the physiology of
the body what is the cell need um and a
lot of things ellen and i like totally
agree on on these on these subjects you
know not restricting
carbs because your body runs on glucose
and you know understanding the hormone
impact of restricting carbs because
that's what your body prefers so it's
basically just studying the physiology
of what your body prefers
and then for it to thrive and then
basically making food choices lifestyle
choices from there but essentially it's
like a balance of energy and stress and
so it's taking as much stress
off of the body as possible so you can
optimize your energy production yeah
because i mean you're right there where
how the body stress is huge on the body
stress takes a huge toll on your body
it's like um the two most taxing things
in our body is digesting food and
digesting stress yes so like learning
how to live a lifestyle that's going to
be lowered in stress not like we can um
minimize it completely but supporting
our body nutritionally so that we can
better handle stress when it does come
our way like we're we're on the same
page with so much of that and actually i
think a lot of people might assume that
we're like completely opposite of an
opinion and while the title of this
episode is vegan versus animal foods you
are not a carnivore you're not like
advocating for carnivore
and there's so much that we align with
which we're going to get into
and we're going to kind of share for
those listening and watching like what
we agree on in finding common ground
before we move forward and kind of
dissect where we kind of go different
ways
and for those of you who are watching
probably already know but maybe not that
i advocate for whole plant foods i am
all about eating living more in line
with nature and yes of course like carb
rich foods whole plants from fruits and
sweet potatoes and whole grains and all
that stuff
lots of fresh greens legumes and that's
that's the way that i advocate for and
it's definitely improved my health
anecdotally right significantly and i've
been eating this way for 15 years and i
will never be going back and i'm sure
and you also have your own
um like stories as well so there we have
where you have like our different ways
of eating and now let's align
oh before i get into that too we just
want to say too that like neither of us
are experts in the field of like science
right in nutrition we're coming from
what we've learned with our own research
and i think this is a perfect like
perfectly matched conversation because
we come from the same
like way of navigating the topic right
as opposed to like if you were to sit
down with like a plant-based doctor and
dissecting science that way or me vice
versa
so i think this is the perfect
conversation for us to have we're the
right we're the right people to be
having this like conversation yes and i
also think that's like one of the main
like
yeah reservations on coming on is just
like well i'm not an expert on like who
am i to like be the authority on these
but that's why we like are the perfect
match for each other because both of us
are lifelong learners like i feel like
that we have both like made it our our
goal to do that and so how do you have a
conversation not necessarily being
experts but being learners of what we
have out there totally yes i think
that's super super important
um okay so let's start with where we
find common common ground and discuss
like let's bring the discussion together
i wrote a list of the things that i
think we have the most common ground on
and i'm gonna i'm gonna go first on what
i love that you promote and then you can
kind of go the other way is that sound
good perfect so i like how you promote
against like processed oils and i know
that you generally use like the broader
umbrella of
of pufas and that means more than just
process oils but but that's one thing
that that we'll get into later but
specifically i love that that you are
advocating against that as like a
significant calorie source yes
and then
another thing just that ultra processed
foods are not health promoting we're on
the same page there
and the promotion of fruit and abundance
like you said earlier and whole plant
carbs like from sweet potatoes to fuel
our body and that the body and the brain
run on glucose and that's going to help
us with our energy
to sustain us and i like that you
promote sourdough bread and fermented
foods i think that that's awesome fully
on the page there
to my knowledge you have a problem with
factory farming right absolutely so
we're on the same page there we'll get
we'll get into the ethical aspect um
actually i should tell people once i
finish this i'll tell people like the
plan for the conversation okay we've got
so much to cover
um i love how you promote healing from
the inside out and not fad dieting or
diet culture like extreme dieting
restrictive diets because we're both in
agreement on like abundance
eating until you're totally satisfied
eating like a woman not like a toddler
i'm fully there i think one of the main
reasons that a lot of people don't do
well in plant disease they're not eating
enough calories specifically from whole
plant sources but in general
um that um
yes not calorie strict i like how you
promote eating at night even
if you're hungry before bed that was
interesting to me and not something that
i hear many people discussing yes but
i i love that that it's just not like
about just restricting your calories
like eat when your body's telling you
that you're hungry so love that um
limiting stress in your life getting
significant sunshine
not obsessing over fats carbs and
protein but just having a healthy
balance i've definitely had in the past
been like oh it's more about this we
need to have more of this and i'm sure
you have in the past as well just look
at all the things that are taught sent
our way
um we're on the same page even about
like workouts mm-hmm yeah um about you
know a few times a week weight
resistance
you do not need to kill yourself over
the
running machines you don't need to be
working out every day
um if you're in a place where you're
having to work out every single day to
maintain your optimal weight like that's
not the place you want to be it
shouldn't be that hard
um
and just like things like super high fat
keto not being optimal i loved your
episode on breaking down popular diet oh
thank you yeah there was a lot that that
was one where i texted you after i was
like i sent you a voice message okay
this is where i agree i really like that
you said this yes obviously we don't
line with this part but
you know but you had like overwhelmingly
positive it's all positive by the way
it's all positive even if she's giving
like hey here are my thoughts on this
like it's still always positive and like
friendly um but yes we so much of like
fuel um as far as like foundational
things we totally agree on that whole
list was was epic and also
um if i could add to it even just like
the kind of water that we drink and
understanding like proper
uh filtration remineralizing um we both
have like a huge emphasis on minerals i
feel like right for sure um yeah you
actually got me on to pristine hydro i
love we love the water system which i'll
put a link below for anyone below who's
interested in checking it out and you
actually went to their headquarters
right yeah yes i got to meet them
one of the owners yes super cool
i think another one would be um
you may have already said the whole like
nature thing like being outside um
syncing up your circadian rhythm and
like getting the right kind of light you
know exposed to your skin and your
eyeballs and like you know not staying
up to 1am looking at blue lights for
sure that's it's the a lot of the
foundational things like we were just in
total agreement and that's like a huge
one like you could be eating a really
well planned diet but if you're going to
bed at 2 a.m every morning and looking
at like the screens and not getting
adequate cycles of getting in the
outside and getting sun and
i'm going to bed at a reasonable hour
when your body's telling you to go to
sleep like yeah yes that's going to
affect a lot that was actually one of
the first things i somebody had like
poked fun at you um in our friend group
of like oh ellen's a grandma she goes to
bed early and i'm like
that's she does actually when she goes
about it like a really reasonable hour
and like it's like amazing for hormone
production so it makes perfect sense why
you're a grandma yeah you're like i'm a
grandma too yeah yeah exactly the same
way okay so
i i should probably preface the rest of
how we want to do the episode so we got
through what we agree on that we're all
also going to break down where we
disagree
and just unfold each topic we're going
to cover nutrition first and then we're
going to go to the ethics and planetary
a little bit we'll just dabble a little
bit towards the end but the
the nutrition part is where we're where
we're really going to unpack things and
i'm sure is where people want to want to
hear us
i feel like as we unpack it and i was
telling her this yesterday i was like i
feel like as we unpack this these we
will find even more common ground of
things of like oh actually we're on the
same exact page about that you know
totally or slightly you know slightly
but at least being able to see and
that's the goal is being able to see
uh eye to eye finding the middle ground
and seeing where we agree
right exactly
for sure so before we get into that then
let's just talk about the fundamental
place where we go separate ways yes so
for you you advocate for like
significant animal food consumption
whereas i advocate for like more high
calorie whole plant foods
and you know like greens
legumes
root vegetables
[Laughter]
don't know what's happening there i read
a lot of story books to just go out
scout this morning too much reading um
healthy fats like avocado
coconut pumpkin seeds flax chia um and
as well to eat a lot of dark leafy
greens so that's where
where i that's where we part ways so
firstly let's start with my first
question to you i think we'll kind of go
back and forth where with each topic
like you can answer first and the next
one i'll answer first and then we
respond oh great that sounds good yeah
which we didn't talk about before so
animal foods first question for you do
you think that they're a necessary part
of a healthy diet and can you do the
pro-metabolic lifestyle in a vegan way
both of these are fantastic questions i
would say the first question is
obviously one of the most popular
questions that you see in this world um
and a couple of like the popular
criticisms i'm gonna list
um i think that they're debatable i
think that there's going to be like some
back and forth of like oh no like you're
wrong about this statistic and this is
what i think about this statistic um and
then i'll get to my most important one
at the at the end but obviously the
first one would be um the
uh i i i'm laughing at the idea of
saying this word but protein i feel like
that's something that people like eye
roll at if they are plant-based because
they're like oh you think that there's
no protein in plant implants absolutely
there's protein in plants i am more
concerned about the absorb absorbability
rate and that's where it that's
debatable i know that animal proteins
are 80 to 100
um absorbable and then plant proteins
are lower than that but that's where
people argue is it 50 to 60 is it 60 to
70 i don't want to get into the weeds of
that but
i think the most important thing to me
is that someone is getting enough
protein and
one of the more important but less
talked about reasons for that is to fuel
the liver and the liver is like one of
the powerhouses of the body because
that's where you are um able to
basically take care of hormone balance
because again what i was talking about
earlier with estrogen dominance and um
the liver just has so many functions and
from my understanding based on the
information i have right now um and
especially from a man named dr ray pete
is that a minimum of 80 grams of you
know absorbable protein is what we're
going for and then of course if you have
a higher metabolic rate you want higher
protein than that if you have a lower
metabolic rate you know
well 80 still being the minimum but 80
to 100 if it's like a lower metabolic
rate
and but of course people are going to
have different opinions on that and that
would be kind of just like my first
point is like are plant protein sources
enough to absorb
enough protein and then get enough for
proper
liver nourishment and then the second
one would be obviously
speaking of absorbability it would also
be the bioavailability of the nutrients
involved and elle and i are on the same
page of just like um you know our your
your plants are only as mineral and
nutrient risk rich as the soil and we're
both like on the same page about like
your soil is so important and the health
of your soil is so important and it's
one of the reasons i'm you know big ag
and factory farming like have created a
major problem for us but um the
bioavailability of nutrients um would be
something that i would be concerned
about and possibly criticize you know
like but i would be open to a discussion
about it
there are a couple nutrients that i
would look for to
um that i don't know if are as bio
available in a plant-based diet
b12 is like a common one of course
there's choline
um taurine glycine and then a big one
would be retinol which we can talk about
in a second yeah we'll go into another
question
and um i guess and zinc would be another
one as well
plant-based diets get criticized for
iron but i also want to talk about iron
in a second as well i don't think that
we are deficient in iron as a as a as a
global um issue there was an iron
fortification program after world war ii
where iron became one of the most
abundant minerals in everything just
everything and a lot of us if we were
eating processed junk in the 90s then we
were exposed to a lot of iron fortified
foods um if we weren't taking a whole
food uh prenatal then we would have had
iron in that iron supplements
multivitamins a lot of these
if we were on birth control big hit of
iron a lot of us are not deficient in
iron
but i will explain the iron situation in
a second but basically uh
essentially if a plant-based diet is not
meeting these through
food
then
what do people look for after that
they'll be like okay well i can at least
supplement this without contributing to
the death of an animal like would you
say that that's kind of like a a logical
step i guess if someone's not meeting
the nutrient needs from from plant-based
right that's like a whole a whole thing
like
the ques that's the question if you
can't eat this way to be healthy then
you can't expect people really to to do
i mean there's gonna be some people who
are ethical vegans be like no matter
what we do this yeah but most people are
gonna be like we do this you know for
the animals in the planet and also we
know that we can do it because because
we could be healthy yes so my question
to you would be like
is there data showing that vegans are
protein deficient that they're not
getting enough protein i i i'm
i mean i i i don't know about the data
that's showing like this or that i think
data is where it gets a little muddy
because um we're not able it's very hard
to study that specific topic um but as
far as the i think it's i think it's
extreme well i think diets in general
are hard to have in a controlled um
environment where you're looking for
excuse me studying diets in a controlled
environment where you're looking for the
function of certain organs i guess and
so
um well you want to look at like vegan
populations and see if they have
deficiencies in things like colon or
choline and like we we just don't see
that from looking at vegan populations
together so like talking about like the
amount of grams that we need as um like
a protein that we need and and
going over the whole if protein is less
bioavailable the question really should
be okay
being a little bit less bioavailable but
do we need as much as that exactly the
animal foods have that's the question is
what do we need to thrive exactly and so
the best way to answer that i think is
to look at vegan populations and you
test their their levels yes of things
like vitamin a and choline and stuff and
we're just not seeing
like lower levels of that for sure so
there's no like to me there's not
evidence that like
you can't get the adequate protein or
that it's even hard to get the adequate
protein sure on a vegan diet because if
you're eating
legumes and just a wide variety of plant
foods really like you're eating an only
grain diet
okay that's not going to be healthy and
for a wide rise a variety of reasons but
if you're eating a wide variety of plant
plant foods and you're getting beans in
your diet lentils a wide variety of it
like you should have no problem getting
sufficient protein sure yeah so this is
this is going to be a topic where you'll
have people back and forth going well
what about this and what about this and
what about this study and i think that's
when you can just look at yourself and
be like hey am i am i thriving do i have
sufficient levels of this this and this
and if not like if not so hypothetically
if it's not the case if you're deficient
in zinc for example um because that's
just a it's a popular one um now you
know you probably have different
thoughts on like well you know were they
eating this this and this you know if
they were deficient in zinc
and have a lot of different
you know like discussions you can go
down there but if someone is deficient
in a certain
mineral for example so like zinc being
one of them
we can look to
nature to see if it's if it's going to
be beneficial for us to take it in in an
isolated form basically so on the topic
of supplementation and this is a whole
yeah thing that we don't need to go like
down but essentially
nature is obviously that like and we
totally agree on this like nature is the
smartest thing when it comes to like how
are foods actually like like working
together and if you think of um a cherry
for example cherry is like a fantastic
source of vitamin c why is it a source
of vitamin c because of everything all
the cofactors with the vitamin c that
work together so we're able to utilize
the vitamin c in our bodies
bioavailable copper and like i said the
cofactors so if we think we can just
strip off the shell of the vitamin c
which is absorbic acid and just take
absorbic acid and have no consequence
right to the body we're fooling
ourselves because it would have to come
from our own reserves and so when it
comes to minerals um
if we are if we are deficient then it
pose my question to that is um the
long-term effects of if you do take a
supplement understanding that if you
take zinc for example which works with
copper you're pulling from your own
copper reserves to be able to sustain
that zinc in the body and well i guess
unless you're taking like a zinc copper
combination well and but both of those
being isolated minerals they need both
the cofactors that are found in the
whole food source and so i think it's
interesting whenever you look at nature
because not only are plants are perfect
example of how things work together like
the cherry but also animal foods being
another one like oysters and liver all
of these contain those same like buddies
as you can see like the the cofactors
and the other everything that works
together to make it work in the body we
can see them equally in plants and
animal foods and animal foods
are a more bioavailable source of that
and so um i think that
that is an important conversation to
have now am i saying you're gonna be
deficient in zinc and therefore you're
gonna have a problem no i can't say that
who am i to say that you would be
deficient in something and you guys take
amazing care of your soil and
locally source a lot of things and these
are i mean the land is very lush here
and so that would be um it's debated i
mean it's it's definitely well that's
why like we could go on like on and on
right about it or listen to scientists
and doctors talk about the
bioavailability bioavailability of
different plants but at the end of the
day i feel like the bet like i'm going
to go back to the best way to tell is if
you look at vegan populations and see if
they're deficient in those things yes
they're not then maybe if they're less
bioavailable or that they are less
bioavailable than like animal foods
maybe we don't need as much as we think
as like you might be inclined to think
like oh look there's more of this but
more isn't always better right the dose
is what makes the poison of what we need
and what we don't need because if you
isolate a certain vitamin or and give it
to them in like a study right if you're
getting too much so i'm going to give
example of like oxygen like if you give
someone 100 pure oxygen
and like that's not going to do well for
them because like oxygen in nature is
only 20 oxygen because we're not
supposed to be having so much so that's
why i don't know if that argument is the
best argument to decide whether like
eating plants is sufficient i think the
best way to look at it is like through
studies totally of human populations and
so if you can say that like if we see
the vegan populations not being
deficient in something like choline and
vitamin a like would that mean that in
your eyes that you could do it healthily
that everyone could do it well i guess
we'll go down to that later right okay
so they're eating a well-planned diet
and that goes for even like
pro-metabolic eating like you could eat
a not a not well-planned way of it right
if someone's like oh i was deficient
these things you'd be like well wait
what were you eating right well i was
eating pro-metabolic right that's the
same thing for vegan there's like a
million different ways to eat vegan you
shouldn't have a problem in my opinion
especially if you're eating enough
calories because the most the more bites
of food that you eat from whole plant
foods the more nutrition you're getting
in your body so
and then well so going back to
like going off of that going back to my
last point that is where my question is
in
uh vitamin a so and we i think we'll
talk about vitamin a like later let's do
that like a few let's go that a few
questions down but so but yeah just cap
it for now yeah do you if it's about
vitamin a should we just wait till we
get to that question well maybe i'll
just state it okay which is that i i
don't know so retinol is going to be
like real vitamin a and then there is
the vitamin a that comes from
plants it's converted into retinol in
your body um and we can talk about is
the conversion rate sufficient
especially with the stress of uh
hypothyroidism like at the base of the
state of the world right now are we are
we
capable of of converting beta-carotene
to to retinol basically should we just
do that one now then uh sure do the one
about vitamin a yeah i'm like okay we
get our notes men we come we come with
notes
um okay let's do that and then we'll
just come back to the next question
which would be like saturated fat so
i'll just go first on that then on
beta-carotene oh go ahead yeah sound
good
okay so the question is like can we get
sufficient vitamin a if we don't consume
vitamin a directly right
like
because we're eating beta-carotene from
plants yes because our understanding of
vitamin a and i learned this in
nutrition school and excuse me in a
nutrition class in college was we will
convert the exact amount of
beta-carotene that we need into retinol
you don't need it from animal foods
because vitamin a toxicity and like we
just like that was like pretty much the
end of discussion it's more in depth
than that definitely for sure but i'm
gonna go back to the same thing of
looking at western cohorts of like vegan
populations and see if they across the
board are showing vitamin a deficiency
and we're just not seeing that at all so
to me that says it is converting
properly and i can i'll say these
studies in a minute so we can put we're
going to put a few studies on the screen
for the ones that we both bring up
so a lot of people bring up like the
bm01 gene yes being like you know people
talk about these conversion issues like
beta beta carotene and choline and
talking about how different people can
convert it well which is true there's a
percentage of it like i think it's like
50 i think earlier you had told me in a
conversation you thought like 90 of
people can't convert
beta carotene not period but yeah so do
you think it's more like a dial or is it
like a all or nothing thing oh i don't
think it's all or nothing i think we
need to have our own different
conversion rates based on our stress
right so some people are going to have
an easier time converting beta carotene
absolutely vitamin a whereas other
people who have maybe a little bit
difficult a little bit more difficult
time they just need to eat more plants
that are rich in beta-carotene and that
and because that should sufficiently
especially knowing what the data is
showing that like vegans are not having
trouble converting and we're not seeing
a vitamin a deficiency in vegans then so
long as you're eating a wide variety of
plants it shouldn't be a problem because
i feel like in order to say that plants
eating plants isn't sufficient then then
we need to be seeing at least data that
like oh a large portion of vegans are
like struggling to get enough vitamin a
sure and just aren't converting it well
but we're just not seeing that so to me
all that we can muddle we can go back
and forth on like the gene and how like
there's you know different people and i
have a spectrum some people can only
convert it 40 or 50
but at the end of the day if we're not
seeing it in the studies that they're
that they're struggling to to convert it
properly then maybe it's not as huge of
an issue as like
the animal-based world is making it does
that make sense so oh wait were you done
well i was gonna say like we would we
would see more vitamin a deficiency
diseases right because we really only
see vitamin a deficiency diseases in
places like
africa and southeast asia where
well what do you define as a vitamin a
deficiency disease well that would be
like night blindness infertility being a
thing are you sure you're saying that
there would be a much lower level no
what i'm saying is a vitamin a
deficiency sorry
deficiency
um manifests itself in so many different
things prior to like that would be like
getting into a stream basically your
level of stress is going to dictate your
ability to make that to make that
conversion and so i think as equally as
important you want to see the stress of
the lifestyle of the people that are
making the optimal conversion
vitamin a deficiency what it manifests
itself as is hypothyroidism and high
cholesterol actually and so as a slew
and a slew of other things but um
basically with a vitamin a
conversion so conversion from
beta-carotene to
retinol there are four main things that
slow down the conversion um or reduce it
and maybe i'll like just list
resources in the yeah like you know um
okay so hypothyroidism would be one
um
oh my gosh i'm blanking right now
hypothyroidism it's hard um we're
pretending to be scientists
hypothyroidism uh
makes the conversion slower a diet that
is very high in polyunsaturated fatty
acids which we can talk about when we
get into the
question uh conversation pufa is just
the short way to say
polyunsaturated fatty acids um and then
also i think the most interesting one is
are the studies that are showing that
the more beta-carotene that you eat
the the more that conversion slows down
and i think that the reason for that if
i'm just offering like a
i don't know just like a fun little
antidote is your body is trying to
figure out what the balance is but
because of so
ideally the solution would be obviously
eat more beta-carotene but if the body
is slowed down from stress there is a
mis i guess like a miscommunication in
the body there's an interference with
like
how to make this conversion to the
perfect amount because we're under so
much totally and that's why i was
bringing up i agree with you there like
that's why i was bringing up the thing
about studies like when they're taking
like maybe the studies right pete is
talking about which um you can you can
give me those links and we'll put that
linked below i'm really curious to see
if those are human studies or if they're
rat studies because rat studies and
animal studies just aren't very it's not
very good way of of studying yeah um
like human population it's very weak
evidence in my opinion so if i could see
that kind of evidence in human studies
then maybe that would be something to
consider
um
but those these studies that i'm seeing
to my knowledge are not taking into
account the stress of someone's life so
like if if someone is eating a
plant-based diet and they're living in a
way that's helpful that we both agree on
like low stress like i imagine we don't
know for sure this is like a hypothesis
especially like i would like to know if
the studies are taking into account that
because maybe their conversion rate will
be a lot better yes you know and it kind
of brings back the philosophical
point of like how do we take the most
stress off of our body how do we
optimize a metabolism and maybe someone
can perfectly make that conversion
possible like like a low stress life
figure that out like maybe they are able
to make that conversion and it kind of
brings me to the question of just like
do you think plant-based is sustainable
for everybody because retinol is this um
very essential in my mind in my in my
opinion
nutrient that people can rely on for
their vitamin a um
resources and we've also
what i think is interesting is studying
or observing like western a price
obviously you're familiar with him but
these were a lot of his observations as
well before we even understood nutrition
science nutrition science is such a new
um
study you know what i mean like it's
we're still in the baby the baby stages
of being able to understand like what
there's so much we don't know for sure
so much we don't know so much we haven't
studied um but instead how can we
observe
basically like what um you know
different cultures and indigenous people
were were eating and i know like liver
was obviously like a huge one that he
discovered that a lot of the um uh
uh conceiving you know people that were
pregnant people that were trying to get
pregnant um
vitamin a being such a fertility you
know nutrient it activates copper it
regulates the whole iron recycling
system all this is so important for
pregnancy and life of course um
but what i see and this is of course
anecdotal this is an anecdotal and what
many of the experts see in this field is
vitamin a deficiency
not getting enough from beta-carotene
therefore they're they're not able to
activate that copper therefore they're
not able to regulate that iron then that
can show up as iron deficiency anemia
other things can lead to anemia as well
but to fix it to fix the anemia the most
important things are
vitamin a copper and so
yeah i it just poses the question of
just like okay can can this be done can
this not be done you know and that's why
i love getting into these conversations
because it's like
yeah like can this be done right well i
there's a couple things that i would say
firstly the thing about anecdotal
evidence of them seeing that i would
like to know like obviously we can't
really know but what
what those people's lifestyles were like
sure and if they're not eating a very
healthy diet right like just a healthy
diet with lots of fresh fruits and
vegetables because the reality is most
people are not eating enough fruits and
vegetables like of all the sickness that
we have in the world and especially the
western countries of all the chronic
diseases we're seeing it's not because
they're eating too much kale like
they're not eating too much fruit like
like right like they're not eating
enough fruits and vegetables that's 100
sure all the things they're eating too
much of vegetables are not it right
right right or not so for seeing people
who are not um like having enough
conversion like why not at least start
there to see that sure right are they
eating in a fresh fruits and vegetables
and on top of it going back to the vegan
cohort stories and i'm repeating myself
but these studies are showing them all
they all have which i'll put up here
there's i have three studies like big
human studies of human populations
showing that none of them had um low
levels of vitamin a they were all in
healthy range so if they were in the
healthy range that's considered healthy
versus like vegan non-vegan is that
considered sufficient for you sure so oh
you're asking oh that was an actual
question yeah yeah it was rhetorical no
no it is yeah no i mean both whatever
but like is would that be considered
sufficient right if you're seeing them
in healthy vitamin a range would that be
enough evidence to like okay maybe
vegans are getting enough vitamin a if i
gave you my like my ideal my my ideal
would be everybody gets this test done
called a full monty iron panel which is
you're able to see
um
vitamin a levels how it's affecting your
copper how your copper is affecting your
iron if i had an ethical conviction for
for veganism like this would be the
first test i would actually do is like
like to understand if i'm making that
conversion rate because what we're
seeing is that
these days people especially in the
western world in the western world these
days a lot of people are over and over
and over again showing that they're
having a hard time converting the
beta-carotene into but you made an
amazing point which is okay well what
are they eating yeah we would have
eating yeah and so we have to look at
the vegan populations to specifically
know like do do they get enough off
plants to convert it properly so i'll
just quickly mention so they can pull up
and if you have any studies you can
totally put them up or if you don't have
them specifically to talk about like we
said we're going to put them all in the
link below i don't know if we'll have
enough room in the notes on like
podcasts or spotify but i'll put them on
my website on the podcast page and
they're definitely going to be in my
youtube it goes to like a google doc
it's just like pages and pages no i'll
put it on like my website like exactly
on the page it should be enough so one
of them is the swiss vegan study the
vitamin a status in vegans we're well
within healthy range and i think like
the most important thing to like drill
home is just that like regardless of all
the mechanistic speculation like vegans
vitamin a status seem to be just fine
like compared to non-vegans so like to
me i feel like it's sufficient like we
could go back and forth on the
mechanistic aspect of the different gene
right of the gene stuff but to me that's
sufficient especially there's one
another one again in 2020 a study of
german vegans vitamin a level's totally
fine and then there's also a new finland
study vitamin a levels were perfectly
fine
um in the finished study there was they
did have like issues with vitamin b12
and d due to like improper
supplementation which we do recommend on
a plant-based diet if you're not in an
area that's like sufficient for sunshine
like
to deal with vitamin d in that way with
supplementation and b12 obviously but
all right let's shift the conversation
we have a lot to get through and it's
already a long episode honestly we could
probably leave our husbands there with
the kids for like four hours and then
just keep going
um but now we're gonna tackle saturated
fats and i think we kind of came to the
conclusion we want to just like i'll
share where i'm coming from with
saturated fat and why i think the way
that i do and then you can share why you
think the way that you do with saturated
fat we probably won't even have that
much to like go back and forth on
because we're just coming at it with
different lenses yeah and so i'll just
share why and then you share why and
then we'll move on to the next topic
perfect okay i do have one question for
you though before i get into it because
it knows for me where to go from there
okay your answer so like my first
question is like do you believe that
elevated ldl cholesterol causes heart
disease i think that it is more about
the particle size but we're on the same
page about that right so like the
smaller the particle of the ld the lel
particle um that is when it's a problem
i from my understanding it's not like
ldl it's like the particle size because
when it's a smaller particle it's able
to enter into
the artery wall and cause that damage
okay
elevated ldl causation with heart
disease is like the most
like studied relationship and strongest
relationship we have like with science
nutrition science and if we don't have
if we can't like accept that then like
we kind of have to throw out like
everything with nutrition science
um
and i just want to kind of explain what
that is to like show that because i do
think a lot of times with saturated fat
conversations it can
get in the weeds about a saturated fat
good for you is it not and at the end
it's like oh wait one actually doesn't
even think that elevated ldl causes
heart disease whereas the other does and
so we kind of have to be on the same
page i think with that at least yeah no
i don't i don't necessarily think the
ldl is good by any means i think it's
the ratio from the hdl to the ldl um so
if ldl is like super elevated and then
the particle size being even more
important to that is kind of what i
meant okay does it make sense yes okay
yeah because we do have like we have
like cohort studies we have genetic
studies which is like about the that
different people have these genetic
basically adaptations or just
in their genes that show that they have
tend to have lower ldl um and they
significantly across the board have like
lower heart disease risk the lower their
ldl is the lower the heart disease risk
and then also the same there's a there's
like 50 genetics
50 genes for that lower ltl one whereas
there's a couple even like high ldl
genes where people just naturally from
birth have a higher ldl and we see
across the board there's one that's like
increases it a little and then one that
like shoots it through the roof and like
time and time again if they do not catch
it early like these people die of heart
disease in their 20s and 30s and it's
like the perfect um
uh what is the word for it it's like the
perfect randomized control trial because
it comes from birth whereas like you
know statin drug studies you're only
seeing like a few years and this is like
from birth so decades so there's that
and then there's also like the cohort
studies
as well as like the um
the statin studies on like
pharmaceutical drugs and i think after
like all that wide body of evidence it's
like really hard to refute that like
elevated ldl cholesterol causes heart
disease to like to review that sure
that's the only reason i wanted to get
into that but with that in mind like to
me i feel like knowing this we have a
strong we have strong understanding
through studies that that saturated fat
does affect ldl cholesterol and and is
cause causation causation with with
heart disease
a lot of times people want to focus on
the serum cholesterol when really
dietary cholesterol yeah a little bit
but for the most part it's the ldl the
saturated fat and it's not just
saturated fat right like i think a lot
of times people want to get into this
it's one of the other it's sugar it's
saturated fat it's but really it's a lot
of things
trans fats you know the processed sugar
refined carbs from um white like white
car like carbohydrates that are refined
um from sugars and flowers but also
saturated fat which is where we disagree
right so the i think the other things we
can agree on right like the do you agree
with that at least okay trans fats trans
fats
causing heart disease raising ldl um
cholesterols and like the refined the
refined sugars so the part that we
disagree on is saturated fat and i think
it really depends when you look at these
studies because there are some studies
right that say well saturated fat
actually did better like it helps lower
lower cholesterol the ldl cholesterol
lowering ldl yeah but the the reality is
we have to look at what were they
comparing it to what did they swap out
the saturated fat for if they swapped
out the saturated fat for trans fats or
refined carbohydrates you might not see
any difference or even an increase right
but if you're sat if you're swapping out
saturated fats
with pufas which i know you don't like
or mufas or whole grains we're seeing
lowered like a crisp consistently across
the board lowered ldl cholesterol and
this comes from like human studies wide
like cohort studies that is showing that
and even if you're taking apart like
let's say there's a study maybe you
present that's like
um not like kind of a weak study and
then maybe out like there could be one
or two that i present that could be weak
but if you take out those ones and just
do the really well mechanized ones like
which i'll put up here they have
consistently saturated fat increases ldl
and swapping it out for
the whole grains and pufas like
decreases it and i'm with you like i
don't think the processed oils like the
pufa oils are healthy but for a
different reason which i think we'll get
into
more so just about that they are
rich in calories and a low source of
nutrition
um but if you're comparing it like to
heart disease and showing what they say
show like that's just what it shows and
so that's where i'm at with that and and
i'll i'll just put those
those studies up on because it really
just depends on what you replace it with
so that's that's why i think that that
the evidence is clear that saturated fat
does cause heart disease and elevates
ldl cholesterol and when you say
saturated fats just clarification do you
also include coconut oil coconut palm
oil or are you comparing
um animal saturated fats with with plant
saturation yeah i think mainly animal
saturated fats like getting a
significant source of your calories in
that because you know the saturated fats
a little bit in lots of different ones
and the chance of someone like just
pounding the coconut oil it's different
than like what's actually happening of
people eating a lot of animal foods that
are rich in saturated fats sure yeah so
i think it's important to
back up and talk about what these fats
are so
saturated fats are single bonded
structures that makes them very strong
that makes them very stable and stable
when i say stable that just means
they're not like breaking apart in the
presence of oxygen light heat and when
you break apart you are creating free
radicals and that can lead to a whole
free radical damage cascade and so they
are the most stable they are the most
strong fats they're also known as like
the warm climate fats and so if you
actually take an animal
from like a cold climate and move it to
like a tropical environment their
body like their fatty tissue will
actually become more saturated and the
same thing with plants and so the reason
we see macadamia nuts
here
locally is they're actually like one of
the lowest uh polyunsaturated fatty acid
content nuts out there because they're
in a warmer climate so the colder you
get the more polyunsaturated fatty acid
um
content nutritional structure of the
fats that you see and the warmer you are
the more saturated the fats are
so because they are strong like i said
um they're more stable number one uh man
i'm trying to get the guy that said this
i love how he says it's dr chris
cresser no no no
we're not going to go by him um talk to
chris something else i he was just
talking about like uh
the studies that have been done on
unsaturated fats in general and like
cholesterol and all that and he was like
hey there are the things that we have in
heart disease sorry um there are the
things we have thought of that we've
tested and we will go back and forth for
decades you know on this and this and
this and this there are the things that
we have not thought about and have not
tested and then they're the things that
we have um can never think about and
they're as far as the cause of heart
disease there have been a lot of people
going hey hey like hey look at me over
here i'm doing this work like please
look at my research like look at look
what i'm doing
and um that they have not been met with
um a lot of like uh
basically just being ignored by the
medical community basically um so dr
brown brother barnes being one of them
um i think he has one of the most
interesting points on heart disease
because of the homocysteine are you
familiar with homocysteine
um i think like plant-based community
would call it like the acid from uh
animal foods so like homocysteine is a
it's a natural acid that elevates after
you eat um protein or animal foods and
then your b vitamins are what break down
that homocysteine like that so it's like
elevates and then b vitamins break it
back down um if you don't have b
vitamins then you're not elevating that
excuse me you're not bringing back down
that homocysteine and so what happens
when you have chronically like
skyrocketed homocysteine levels for a
long period of time what it does is
actually burns holes in the arteries and
then plaque comes and tries to um
basically regenerate it and heal your
body is trying to self-heal
and um so essentially there's two ways
you can go with that one is okay well
let's cut out the animal foods for sure
like they're causing this like elevation
and homocysteine like this is the
problem and dr broda barnes is like okay
well let's talk about the b vitamins
first off why are you deficient second
why are you not absorbing b vitamins and
his
conclusion his big thing is
hypothyroidism so an under functioning
thyroid hormone if you have an under
functioning thyroid you're not
absorbing b vitamins as well and
therefore you're not breaking down the
homocysteine um and he was able to
reverse heart disease in many many many
many many patients by treating them with
um
thyroid hormone and really healing their
thyroid so a lot of alternative
practitioners will actually they they do
understand this and they will give b
vitamins as part of a heart disease um
like protocol and dr berto barnes is
like yeah that is an option but i'm just
going to treat the thyroid i honestly
think that he literally was just
supplementing with thyroid hormone alone
just to see what happens you guys can go
look into his work yourself i don't want
to miss i don't want to misquote him um
and obviously like i said i'm not i'm
not an expert on these things i'm just
bringing different things into this into
this conversation but yeah i think that
um it presents an interesting question
of just like are we are we hyper focused
on something where there is a bigger
picture involved and as far as saturated
fats like um in controlled studies you
can you can cause saturated fats to
raise blood cholesterol levels for sure
what you're bringing up is the ldl
obviously um and that is one where i
have not um and i can obviously list
like illicit studies as well but i have
not seen a causal relationship with
saturated fats in ldl but more
importantly that size of the ldl what is
causing the degeneration basically of
the lipids like what is causing them
it's another cause i think
these people are gonna be like who is
this like metamedical um question no
we're just we're just sharing like what
we've read and learned you know what i
mean i think that there is um good
reason to
explore other
answers especially here's a question
then try to interrupt but why do you
think that the medical community is
rejecting his studies is it possible
they're flawed studies well so medical
community back in the well back in the
1920s so there was a good
um
there are people that believe that there
was a good reason to
perpetuate the saturated fats are are
bad um idea because these um saturated
fats sorry polyunsaturated fats
being good because there was a massive
need to sell a ton of crops of seed oils
vegetable oils and so um
i guess it was yeah i think it was the
1920s whenever
some
farmers and actually this is interesting
to look into it just as far as saturated
fats and polyunsaturated fats on the
metabolism because these farmers were
like how do we um like fatten up our
livestock and feed them less food with
um or like feed them less with less
resources does that make sense yeah make
them satisfied keep them fat but with
less resources and so they started with
coconut oil
um and when they fed them coconut oil
their livestock got leaner they were
more active and then they started losing
i already said that they started losing
weight um and then they were hungrier
because their metabolisms were speeding
up and so they were like oh okay no
like that we don't need that um and then
they started feeding them corn and uh
soy bean oil and they found that the
opposite happened they were able to
reduce their metabolic rate by 50
percent they were able to feed them less
and they were continuing to get fatter
and fatter and fatter this is why
cancer patients are fed soy oil soy oil
to keep them from losing weight and so
the paint industry at the same time
found out that they could make
paint with petroleum instead of seed
oils and so they were like oh this is
like such a cheaper option
and they needed to get rid of seed oils
and so
they basically um
they they rode on this one study they
found that the seed oil was able to
chemically dissolve the cholesterol the
blood cholesterol but that poses an
interesting problem because cholesterol
there is there to protect you
cholesterol is just a response it's a
symptom um it's actually a healing agent
and so um basically that was the study
that they were right writing on and then
there was a i believe possibly a reason
um
financially to keep the saturated fats
are bad
polyunsaturated fats are good and then
obviously the health and the medical
literature are
you know changed from there i'm not
sitting here questioning um yeah no can
i respond to that yeah okay so i find i
really want to see that study i'm
interested to see i haven't heard of
that study from what was the same again
the study with the seed oils no the one
with the um
thyroid oh dr brother barnes yeah yeah
so i'd like to see that one um which
we'll get to after the episode um but
about the okay there's a couple things
about the incentive and like basically
the corruption behind science i think of
anything there's a much stronger
argument
of animal agriculture big ag having
influence in studies than there is in
seed oils
seed oil big seed oil there's really not
a big seed oil industry to my knowledge
that influences
our nutrition science like bag act big
ag is so huge and they're so powerful
with what they they fund tons of studies
and they fund it in a way like to where
their researchers know that if they
don't give them favorable outcomes
they're not going to fund them again so
they have influenced so much when it
comes to nutrition science and i haven't
heard of that at all when it comes to
like seed oils that store that's a
really interesting historical story and
i'm sure that it's it's accurate i'm
curious though how it actually
influenced science like who paid for the
science to show that like seed oils were
good for you sure i'm
skeptical that like if the nutrition
science would be hesitant to like if it
was a well-done study that they wouldn't
want to use it i would be
i would think that it might not be a
well-done study because big ag is so
powerful they would want to fund that
kind of study to show saturated fat but
back in with that just to play like
devil's advocate yeah ansel key is the
one that um started the saturated fat is
bad uh
i guess like
um trajectory
he was met with absolute skepticism
absolutely world health organization was
just like no like like we we don't we
don't agree with this like there were
there was a lot of skepticism with him
as well and so i'm just playing devil's
advocate yeah
no no yeah heart disease was at its peak
like in the 60s before the processed
foods industry
so i think that's really i think that's
important to consider so if we're really
going to say it's like processed foods
and a lack of like nutrition from like
whole foods then why why was heart
disease so prevalent like post-world war
because really post world war we started
world war ii we started to get have more
affluence so we started to eat more meat
more animal foods it used to be once a
week and then it turned into like an
everyday thing and that's kind of when
we started to see like the skyrocket in
heart disease so to me that's kind of
like a direct correlation
in the 1960s well no it was at its peak
by that time okay so
the heart disease peaked at 1960 there's
a lot of heart disease before the
processed foods industry picked up so to
me it feels like
it's it's a good way to understand that
like maybe it's both sure right
sure i'm always open to yeah like
examining both i think the seed oils
played a
massive role in in uh being a huge
contributor to disease and cancer and um
yeah we're like on the same page there
when it comes to processed foods like if
someone's eating trying to be like i'm
eating pro metabolically but they're
eating like you know pizza hut four
times a week you're gonna be like wait a
second let's like and they're saying i
don't feel well you're like okay let's
try to get out of the processed foods
and that's like exactly what i would say
for sure because because it is the
convenience factor plays a huge role
which i'm sure you and i
agree on like you and i are both like
one of the rare people that actually
takes a lot of care into like what we
feed our family what we bring into our
home because it we know it is easy to
just grab the processed stuff meet our
kids the process stuff but neither of us
are like that i think that's another
reason why we bond so much because we're
like yes make home make things from
scratch homemade figure out like you
know garden and like um get things with
like nutritionally dense soil so like
we're both fully on the same page i
think i think the part where we end up
like splitting a little bit is more like
is it just the processed food stuff or
is it also animal food stuff sure yeah
yeah so with that why don't you go into
saturated fat your views
yeah saturated fats basically my my
views at at this point on them what are
that they are healthy and done in the
right way just like i can't say meat is
healthy like there is meat that is
absolutely unhealthy depending on how it
was raised with the cattle with the
livestock were
eating and that goes for any animal i
think another interesting point is uh
like mycotoxin exposure and just like a
whole realm of things that are that
could be inside of a saturated fat and
animal protein that we're not examining
um at this point and i think that we
should i think there should be a ton
more studies on red meat saturated fats
um and looking at a you know looking at
it from different angles but what i do
want to talk about is kind of just the
chemical
aspect of a saturated fats because
before we get into like um is it good is
it bad i think it is important to
understand like what it is and it wasn't
something that i studied until like um i
think three years ago and i was like
what even is that like what even is
saturated fat so
um saturated fats it is a um it is a fat
with a single bond and so that saturated
means it's like saturated with hydrogen
and then monounsaturated fats and
polyunsaturated fats would be
something with one or more double bonds
and the more and more and more double
bonds you have the more
flexible and pliable the fats are it's
the reason that a saturated fat is um
uh solid at room temperature and then
polyunsaturated fats are liquid
for the most part and so the more
unsaturated you are
the more kinks you have in the system
and therefore the more susceptible you
are to um oxidative uh damage in the in
the presence of light and heat and
light heat and oxygen
and so
what we were
kind of discussing before is basically
what we see
as far as fat
in our food it changes based on what
your what your climate is and so when
you get to more warm and tropical
environments you see food moving to a
more saturated environment and it's a
more stable environment
there is a whole
entire
piece that this guy dr christopher i
don't know why i'm forgetting his last
name but i will link that i'll put it
right here in the screen okay he kind of
goes into like okay what even
how how does our body even respond to a
saturated fat and like what is it even
doing for us
um and i think it's wonderful but
basically saturated fats they they
increase your metabolism they're
pro-metabolic and they are very
protective to the body um
we've talked about breast milk before i
think like saturated fats being the
majority of the fats that are in breast
milk however i'm actually really curious
now if a woman lives in a colder climate
if her breast milk is actually higher in
polyunsaturated or you know unsaturated
fats versus saturated in a woman that's
in a warmer
i mean i would like to see a study on
that i don't know it's probably never
been done but it's just a thought that
i've had um and so saturated fats um
they're yeah like i said very stable and
i think that this is something that
people are not really looking at because
oxidative stress free radical damage is
such a key component to disease
dysfunction cancer and
i think the demonization of saturated
fats is at this point in time not
something that i've seen as a as a
causal effect um
of heart disease of heart disease and
when we look at
we can look at
cultures who have been thriving off of
saturated fats for
um you know a very long time you can
look at pacific islanders and people
that live in warm and tropical
environments where saturated fat is by
and large the majority of the fats that
they're eating because
that is the fat that it's that's um in
you know in front of them we're talking
about macadamia nuts um you will find
local macadamias no sorry macadamia nuts
here on the islands because that nut is
um lower in um polyunsaturated fatty
acids because it's in a in a warmer
environment in fact like the
pro-metabolic approach to nuts there's
like a list of
highest in polyunsaturated fats and
lowest in polyunsaturated fats and
macadamia nuts is like okay this is the
one if you're going to eat a lot of nuts
like this is a great one because there's
not a lot of polyunsaturated fatty acids
in there we can go over like the effects
of polyunsaturated fatty acids on the
metabolism in a second but essentially
saturated fats protective pro-metabolic
they
act as like this um
honestly just go look at this article i
mean we could spend all day talking
about this but my um
my opinion of saturated fats at this
point is that they are healthy um that
cultures have been thriving off of them
that have had access to them for
you know centuries and centuries and
especially the pacific islanders the
three that i'm thinking of there's three
um and maybe i'll i'll link the studies
that were done on them in the show notes
but those that had the saturated fats as
the mat as the majority of the saturated
fats in their diets
heart disease is almost non-existent
it's either extremely low or like
completely free um i know that the uh
masai messiah is another example of that
who eat a ton of like milk and blood
even and a lot of animal foods and heart
disease was almost non-existent in them
as well and so
when we're looking at different cultures
i don't know if we have
the evidence to say like oh saturated
fats definitely the cause of heart
disease because we have the opposite i
guess on the other side to
to observe
okay two questions one question and one
thing to say though i i want to
understand you correctly you're saying
saturated fat in like place the specific
places but wasn't saturated fat i mean
that is what across the entire world
what what people are eating to survive
because sure like to survive and thrive
so what would make that different for
like pacific islanders versus i mean
obviously it's not everywhere so like
rural china for instance like is an
example where their traditional diet ate
very little animal foods it was like
something used to like sprinkle on their
food and it was predominantly
plant-based and they had very very low
heart disease and i guess when you're
comparing would be like what's the
longevity like do you know like what
their longevity was like in those areas
longevity there is a the one that i'm
thinking of of it starts with the t
takavana takavana is that sound
familiarity as a pacific islander they
looked at longevity heart disease cancer
um
you know them across the board um but if
you're asking if yeah so you're asking
basically if each of these studies
looked at longevity as well yeah i i
don't know that enough to have my head
if all yeah no i'd like to see those i
want to look at that okay i think we got
through most of it basically that we
want to get through let's move on to the
next one um or is there something else
you want to say well just the idea of
maybe cholesterol
being the symptom i think that is
something that is really really not
talked about and the statin drug
industry
is obviously a big one and i think that
um
yeah i think that cholesterol needs to
be a conversation as far as like okay
why is cholesterol elevated in the first
place it's a result of um that coming
out as a as a as a healing agent and
then like i said you can also be high in
cholesterol if you are hypothyroid
obviously and berta barnes was showing
this in his work um but then that
vitamin a deficiency there's so many
things that can uh lead to a high
cholesterol and i think that it's not
really this is not really part of the
conversation but i think that i think
that that is just a um it's something
that we i think would be neutral
neutral on as far as the cause of high
cholesterol
so interesting i thank you for sharing
all that honestly there's so much stuff
that we're just like from different
perspectives and
maybe different things that we're not
considering in different ways so when
you hear about it it's nice to hear each
other's perspective on it
okay so let's move on to pufas okay is
pufa really the problem or is it just
process oils you go first
um okay so pufas
you've talked a bit about it yeah but
why don't you just like yes i mean so
essentially the oils obviously are the
biggest offender and then pufas um and
basically what you need to think about
with pufas is they have been shown and i
know that we've talked we talked about
this before the episode um but they have
been shown to basically in short like
create less resilience
rest less resiliency in your body as a
as a reaction to stress
also increase serotonin activity which
you may hear that and think great that's
the happy hormone right it's definitely
not the happy hormone um serotonin
elevates as a result of stress to slow
down the metabolism um and that i mean
that has been demonstrated in animal
studies but i but also human studies but
i think that the um it's the most
obvious in preparation for hibernation
so elevated serotonin is how animals
basically prepare for for hibernation
pufas also um
they can increase estrogen activity
which can create a major problem over
time and lead to things like breast
cancer and fibroids and endometriosis
and um it i'm sure like one of your
follow-up questions for this will be
like okay well how much like how much
and like like what what excess are we
talking about
number one i think it depends on the
person but number two um these are not
the studies that i that i have in front
of me either but i think that excess
foofa is the conversation here i don't
think that that polyunsaturated fats are
evil or or toxic i think that
in my opinion like they don't make sense
as far as a biological perspective to
make that the majority of like the
calories in your diet they are very high
in calorie totally um i'm with you there
yeah and just an observation of nature
as well of just like the the foods that
the animals
gravitate towards to slow down their
metabolisms
and
there have been a few studies where
they've swapped polyunsaturated fatty
acids with
saturated fats in humans to watch
metabolic rate and those are really
interesting um but essentially excess
pufas are my problem we're on the same
page of like no i don't think that food
is is toxic by any means i think that in
its whole state like in its raw state
it does of course contain anti-nutrients
that are just there to protect to
protect the nut from being eaten one of
them is um
inhibiting digestive enzymes actually
and so you're like inhibiting the
absorption of the
minerals and the nutrients from it
but with the caveat that you can reduce
these um you can see these in squirrels
when a squirrel goes and gets a nut they
don't go eat the nut right away they
actually bury it like an inch under the
ground and that allows the nut to sprout
and to release some of the
anti-nutrients that are harmful to the
nuts excuse me the squirrel's body
and inhibit the absorption of things
like calcium and whatnot and so i think
if nuts are properly prepared meaning
soaked you know soaked in water um
sprouted is even better then you're
looking at a much better whole food
source okay so i'm totally with you
there on the soaking and sprouting of
nuts and legumes even and beans
to help with the bioavailability of the
nutrients fully on board there i think
that it's more helpful to to describe
whole food sources of these foods and
then separate them from like processed
puffa oils because i think they
do different things in the body
and
attribute to our wellness in different
ways or lack of wellness so if we just
say like poof is across the board like
people like oh i'm so afraid of nuts now
i shouldn't eat any nuts right when
really like studies actually do show
like better health outcomes eating nuts
and i think part of that is because of
the like the fiber content and the
nutrients in them that people are
swapping out as opposed to like
processed foods so i think it does
attribute to like better health for this
doesn't mean pound the nuts this is
where we agree this is something we
figured out like
down there in our friendship i think i'd
read a poster or something i was like
ooh i'm so with you i'm not like
overdoing the nuts you don't just like
pound it and pound it and pound it
because
now we have access to like bulk bins
where it's just easy to just get a whole
pound just right in your hand when
really the amount of care it takes to
like open properly open and
get a nut out is a lot of work and so
you really wouldn't be eating like that
many but there is uh benefits based on
like like studies that we're seeing
for health outcomes um and and better
weight management even which is
surprising um just eating some nuts here
and there and replacing i think part of
that like if you're gonna talk about
like let's say like a lasagna that i'm
gonna make and i would use like a cashew
sauce as opposed to a processed cheese
sauce oh yeah you know what i'm saying
so to me
process vegan cheese or not right like
that would be a different like you would
probably say that like dairy cheese
actually i know you would say that um
it's like healthier than ever than a
vegan cheese like a processed cheese but
if you're just comparing like my family
i think that like a cashew type of sauce
not saying you should eat a ton of
cashews right but when you are gonna
here and there throughout the week
everyone smile that that that kind of
makes sense to me whether it be better
health outcomes yeah and it's a sauce
meaning it's a um
it's complimentary to to the meal it's
not the meal and i think that that is
what makes the biggest difference for
sure and i think it's very rare that
someone's getting the majority of their
calories from nuts though like yeah like
people can't overdo it though when you
think about it like like like we said
the bulk bins and then also nut butters
like just slathering it on everything
um but
in mind of like a whole foods
plant-based diet i do think there's
benefit to including it in your diet
like nuts and seeds especially like hemp
seeds i just love hemp seeds i think
that's a great way to go and i'll just
put up a couple
like studies about
um like nuts showing that they have
better health outcomes um but i the main
reason i don't like pufa oils is that
they're calorically dense and nutrient
poor so like it's very easy with oils to
get a lot of your calories from oil and
then you don't have as much room for
getting calories from
nutrient-dense whole foods
and
the thing is like it encourages weight
gain because there's so much calories in
such a small little bit that it doesn't
actually fill up your stomach and you're
more likely to not feel satiated for not
getting enough calor for the fact that
it's not filling up your stomach and
then also because it's not nutrient
dense
and because one of the reasons why i
think people crave foods that are like
like eating too much or not eating
healthy foods is because they're not
getting enough nutrients in their body
and part of that reason i think that
well i think that oil can make it harder
for that so like process oils oh okay
wait so you're saying you don't
believe that the oils have an effect on
the metabolism
no i do i i
i think it does affect your um
the way that you engage in food because
if you're eating foods with a lot of
oils in it you're significantly
increasing your calories but not
increasing your nutrition so does that
make sense what i'm saying yeah so
basically going back to the cow study
you would like to see
because the coconut oil and the and the
oils that they were feeding them
obviously were the same in calories but
you're saying you would like to see
maybe a human study where it's like
coconut oil
i just think oils in general like okay
so we could get in the weeds right and i
would like to listen to more things
about like you know certain oils are
like there's studies saying that like oh
a little bit of olive oil is like
totally is fine oh yeah right you know
like that's especially for someone who's
like um doing fine with their weight
like a little bit olive oil in your diet
should be fine so it's not like to be
like a fear of oil right but to but and
that's one thing that we agree on is
like food abundance and not like just
restricted like i can never try this
yeah not like orthorexia no not at all
but like an understanding of like if
every day every meal day in and out or
the foods that you're eating that are
processed have oils in them and you're
cooking with oils processed food oils
right and most of the processed foods
are just filled with oils and so for you
you label pufas right and for me i just
say oils because like i'm just like
they're just oils and most of them are
not olive oil and coconut oil in the
processed foods they're safflo they are
the oils you're talking about but i'm
just saying oil because i'm like i think
oil is adding calories but not adding
nutrition so if you're eating like the
majority of your calories from whole
foods whether that's with animals or not
although i will say that with plant
foods
is different because plants tend to be
lower in calories than animal foods
you're with plant foods you're
increasing your fiber and water content
and the nutrition because there's all
the and the antioxidants and the micro
nutrients like wonderful nutrition and
then you are less likely to eat more
than you should be you're going to be
eating in abundance to your own
satisfaction until your body feels full
and your mind tells you to be done and
you're getting more nutrition as opposed
if you're eating a meal with a lot of
oil like 400 calories from oil you
easily can for sure and then you're like
why am i gaining weight why am i not
losing weight and you're just eating
tons of oils out your day which because
it's it's very sneaky like you just
think that's one little tablespoon
that's 120 calories of just pure fat
right whereas if you're if you're eating
whole foods you're less likely to be
eating
too much of something for sure for sure
yeah because processed sugar is the same
way and so processed foods these ultra
processed foods are filled with that
stuff they're filled with oil they're
filled with processed sugar and it
confuses your body and your brain and
it's like super high in calories and low
in nutrients for sure i feel like we're
on the same page we just use different
language yeah and maybe look at it
slightly differently i don't know no i
think that we are on the same page of
if you remove
reduce if you reduce one thing in your
diet like we're not telling you to
remove the entire thing and be like i
said orthorexic about it but we're on
the same page of like even if this is
the one the one change you make like yes
you will see health benefits from it
absolutely because not only will you
reduce those calories but you're going
to replace them with nutrient dense
calories but the oils are like i think
inarguably harmful like for sure um yeah
and even though we might use slightly
different language and say it in like
maybe different reasons i think we come
back to like kind of the same thing and
they do a whole host of beneficial
things it does you a benefit by just not
making that a staple of what you're
cooking with exactly and then being
careful to read ingredients like so many
people don't look at the ingredients in
their pro in their food packaging yes
and safflower oil
all that stuff um processed sugar um all
just laid in with those foods so we're
on the same page fully right there
i think did we cover it is there
anything else no i don't know i have no
thoughts good
i have no thoughts
all right so we just decided we have we
had like five other top points we wanted
to hit and this is just really way too
long and maybe we'll do another episode
one day sure hitting the other points
but let's go into something that i think
is a really interesting conversation
which is the ethical component and we
both want to get into there so i think
i'll just ask you the first questions
which is what are your thoughts on
the ethical reasons for eating
plant-based well maybe a clarification
like a clarification question first
which is what is the
i guess like chronological logic like
clarify for me the chronological logic
of
ethically not eating animals it's like
this isn't um well you know i'm not
gonna put words in your mouth you tell
me like chronological
logic of just like what's the first
thought and how does it lead to that
how does it lead to eating vegan yes
or the omission of animal foods yeah
okay
i think
i think it goes to
just wanting to cause the least amount
of harm that's reasonably possible
i think
you do not have to be an animal lover to
gravitate towards that because i am not
an animal lover a lot of people might be
surprised to hear that i don't gravitate
towards
just like naturally just super obsessed
with animals like some of my friends are
right like i actually remember a story
which might help ease your mind a little
bit like growing up we had a family dog
my mom had called me and said john luke
died yes his name was john luke laugh
and um
he was
and so he died and so i was out on the
street with my friend who
kesley still one of my best friends
today from high school she's a huge
animal lover neither of us were being at
the time we were in high school like
high school
and
i was like i held up the phone she's
like what's wrong i was like oh my dog
died and she started crying and i was
like why are you crying like i like i
wasn't even crying
a lot of people cry when their dog dies
like it's fully understandable i don't i
just don't i just my whole life haven't
naturally been someone some people are
just more naturally drawn to animals
than others and i i do love animals
but i think the reason i tell this story
is that you don't have to be like a huge
animal lover to want to cause
to not support their suffering sure like
to not be
paying for their harm right sure yeah
while i am not inclined to go run up and
just like have a big farming farm
sanctuary on my land and have like 20
animals on my property like while i'm
not inclined for that i am inclined to
not want to see them suffer and i know
that by paying for it i'm supporting
their suffering and i know i don't want
to see them suffering right like i
wouldn't want to look at it
so i that's where i got to why i
wouldn't want to support it and even
though i started eating plant-based for
my health i actually had no ethical
component at the time i i remember even
like having dinner with my dad and other
people being like do you care that we're
gonna eat steak and i was like i don't
care i'm just doing this for my health
that was my logic and my mindset at the
time just so just a backstory to
understand that like i think it's easier
to relate to too knowing that there are
people who are like that right that you
don't have you're like well i'm not
naturally someone that's just gonna be
obsessed with animals like some peop
some people are
and that could be you could just go into
that i wonder what stems from that
um but i do think that you cannot want
to see them suffer and so that's when i
didn't have any ethical connection to
them i hadn't even considered the
animals when i was eating plant-based
for a while like years until i had
watched this speech by gary yourofsky
called the best speech you'll ever hear
which you sent to me yes i don't know if
you're watching i watch it oh you did
okay so um that speech i just like and
part of the reason why i think i was
more receptive to it at the time of
watching this because i was already
eating vegan oh and like you're already
eating that way so it doesn't feel as
threatening yeah as cause he comes down
really strong yeah but the way that he
spoke just
spoke in a way that was so logical to me
that i was like wow i want nothing to do
with this i can't believe i had never
considered the animals before
because
it's it's not like you have to be
like just wanting to go work on a farm
and love your like a sanctuary and just
want to be around them all the time but
you also don't want to see them suffer
just like i know if i saw someone
beating a dog in front of me i would
want to go and stop it my inclination
would be like
heck no this is horrible and most people
feel that way actually
the difference stems from
whether it's a necessary part for your
health right so that's why some people
are like well
and also there's people will be like
well there's a difference between
beating a dog versus just killing them
with that without much quote unquote
suffering
to be able and that's where we part ways
i think yeah not fair yeah because i
think that um another thing i also hear
is like uh kindness like like showing
them like as much kindness as possible
to
um to the animals and i think that's
where i
it always is going to circle back to
what you just said which is well are
animal foods necessary for for our
health do they help us thrive do they
help us survive or i guess are they
necessary that's that's the warm
question for sure yes um because of
course i think there's more of a
mainstream idea a mainstream vegan idea
that i've seen that i think you would
actually disagree with which is like we
don't eat animal foods we don't we can
make the taste we can make our food
taste like animal foods and you won't
miss it but i i'm not eating animal
foods for the taste like i'm eating it
because because i believe that the most
nutrition nutritious and bioavailable
food
avail available to us and so
i think that with the ethical component
i think that the logical
part of like i don't want to see an
animal suffer and that leading to
not eating animals is a super
interesting conversation um because
i know that like taking that same like
objective logic doesn't work for some
things but i know people are like well
it's death like it's we're talking about
death here what's an example where it
doesn't work oh well this is
i mean this is just more like an
objective thing of like hey if i can't
imagine doing that then i'm clearly then
we no one is meant to do that does it
make sense so like you could apply the
same to i'm trying to give a really like
like a light-hearted example maybe like
um
performing surgery like if i can't
perform surgery then no one's meant to
get surgery done therefore like no one
can possibly stomach this
and i think it comes back to us this is
just my personal opinion okay um i think
it comes back to us moving away from
community because at the end of the day
they're
as far as i can imagine in my mind and
we can absolutely evolve like we can i
always welcome change and evolving as
far as i can imagine right now there
will always be people that can stomach
like um killing an animal especially for
their sustenance and for their health
and do it in a way that is extremely
honoring to the animal's life um
and i think in moving away from
community we've forgotten that
we are all different and that like just
because i
you know i'm not saying i cause i can't
i can picture myself you know hunting or
fishing
and it's not something that is like
gruesome or um
uh i'm trying to be very careful my
words here obviously for like the sake
of the audience you and i have talked
about this before yeah um but
yeah so i think that in moving away from
communities i think that there has been
a forgotten part of we can all have
different interests skills passions um
things that we can imagine ourselves
doing one person is amazing at growing a
tomato and that is like their thing and
you've experimented with uh making
sourdough bread and it was just like
brought so much fulfillment and life to
you
um
and i
you know across the board like i've
heard like this these are the same exact
words that same description of like how
fulfilling and um
primal and just like rooted it felt to
provide food for yourself through
something that you go and get yourself
or that you know where it's sourced
basically and you know how the animals
are treated um
there is an interesting um i don't know
it's an interesting conversation because
i don't know if we can see you know
someone who i know some people might
laugh at this word but like ethical
hunting would just mean that you are
extremely aware of what wildlife is
around you who are the moms who are the
dads who were the babies um
you know never i mean i remember um kyle
telling my husband telling me that like
if and this is kind of like like
obviously hunting culture as well like
anyone that has grown up with a family
hunting knows that like if you if you
shoot the wrong buck like if you sheet
the wrong beer or beer deer that year
like you are going to be like
tethered like just like just absolute
like just how
maddening that is because that was the
one based on um you know working with
conservation and like uh in the local
organizations to um to know exactly what
animal to bring home for your food and
so i think that is way different from
factory farming of course where we're
extremely
disconnected from our food sourcing but
as far as the ethical piece as far as
the ethical piece i think it always
comes down to
who defines right and wrong you know
where we find that
definition within ourselves or like how
we would define that globally like
globally like what is right what is
wrong how do we know
the definition of right and what right
and wrong
and can we argue with somebody else's
different definition of right and wrong
um and so it's not i don't see this as a
black and white answer i see it as this
is a cool conversation and i don't know
that i personally see
the logic of um if i can't stomach you
know killing an animal for my food that
means that no one should does that make
sense yeah well when i was speaking
about the house between that for myself
that i wouldn't want to see it therefore
i'm not going to support it myself oh i
see right yeah yeah right and it's
interesting i think you're um well
that's a thought to say that i'm not
advocating for people to do it though
sure but just from that's what i meant
when i was saying that um but i think
it's really interesting what you said
about the community aspect that people
have different gifts as you if you will
or different things that they're good at
but something that you said was about
that some people can stomach it right to
me that's an important piece to note in
that if we're really going to talk about
our health and what's going to make us
thrive
food shouldn't be hard to stomach like
it shouldn't be like it shouldn't be
like oh like like what is our natural
food you can look at every mammal or
every species right like it's what looks
delicious to them in their natural state
so one reason why we know fruit is
perfect for us as humans is the way our
hands are the way we can reach and grab
it the way the color is it's appealing
to us just the way that it is
and there's nothing appetizing about the
skinning and dismembering of an animal
now you could argue that some people are
like there's hunters that are fine with
it and that maybe over a long period of
time they start to you know certain
people who get really accustomed to
eating raw meat that that maybe they can
find
um
positive experiences from that but
there's a difference between positive
experiences from enjoying sourcing your
own food because i relate to that i
enjoy i love sourcing my own food from
my gardens the most it's just such a
rewarding thing making things from
scratch but why can't we just do that
plant-based is the is the question right
sure so if we if okay i have a question
for you at the end about that
but um when it comes there's a
difference i think between
enjoying sourcing your own food
versus like finding it appetizing to
skin and dismember an animal and
de-feather them and like it's a really
grueling not like messy process that i
think
most people
would not find enjoyable to watch or do
and i think if you grow up being
conditioned to enjoy that that's
different than what our natural biology
is because what our natural biology is
we like as children we are inclined to
do that unless we're going to do it out
of survival because we have no other
choice of what to eat so i think that is
a good argument on what's best for our
health because we can look at our
biology our natural desire to not want
to hurt animals and what we actually t
we actually teach children not to hurt
animals right like if if they are taught
to hunt right they're only taught to
hurt certain animals or kill certain
animals other animals are like
completely off limits you teach them to
actually be super kind to them not just
to not kill them but like don't pull on
the kitty's tail like that'll hurt the
kitty like be gentle don't hit well be
gentle to the baby duck like all all of
that we teach them to be kind
so the real i think like question i
guess you could say a philosophical
question is like why would why is it why
would we do that for certain animals why
are we inclined to do that right but not
others because i think it's because
we're just told and taught that these
animals are for eating while others are
not and because if we over time our
whole childhood are told over and over
again pigs are for eating deer or for
eating cows are for eating but cats and
dogs and dolphins and whales and
gorillas like we need to preserve them
and be kind to them and i think
and and take care of them right like if
you see one hurting in the street you
might even be kind to like help it even
if you're not a huge animal lover right
like at least call a veterinarian and
speaking of like the hunting culture
you're talking about and the care that
they make to not kill certain animals to
me that speaks much more about their
desire to preserve the population so
they can keep killing them than it is to
actually caring about the animals so i
guess that my question is when it comes
to this is that
two questions one is it are there
certain animals that you think are
okay and good to kill for food while
others we shouldn't kill for food and
then the second part is that is it
important to you that we cause the least
amount of harm to animals before killing
them like is that considering their
suffering suffering part of your thought
process
so i'm trying to get where to start um
because there's a couple things i do
want to address about what you said as
well and then maybe i'll go into into
that into your questions
but um i do want to address the
appetizing thing because i think that
that is uh i mean i've heard this from
from just discussions with a lot of of
vegans i am hard-pressed to find
somebody that is appetized by looking at
a bunch of kale to be honest um and so i
think that the i think the logic of like
um only eat things that are completely
appetizing to you and and that being the
logic behind it i guess
it it um i guess it it falls into
uh more conversations from there do you
see what i'm saying yes but i think when
i'm framing the question like that it's
not like everything you eat has to be
like oh i i want to eat raw beans in
their natural state it's more so that
it's not
unappetizing like like it is beautiful
and very um enjoying like there's very
there's a lot of joy to be had with
picking fresh greens even like kale like
you said and there's nothing
unappetizing about it whereas like
dismembering an animal and skinning them
and taking part like that is
unappetizing for i think most people now
you could you could argue that's just
because they're not around it but i
think there's a reason why like we take
kids to go strawberry picking but we
don't take them to like a trip to the
slaughterhouse unless you're like in
like a hunting family and you're trying
to teach them to become hunters sure
right so other than that there's a
reason i think why we don't because we
don't find it advertising we don't we
don't want to see the process like
there's a reason why you're not posting
on instagram like look i'm going to show
you this animal getting dismembered
because nobody wants to see it but like
if you were to show kale getting picked
from a garden but maybe not kale for you
like let's think of a vegetable right
that it like sweet potato that would be
a beautiful thing to show like people
would want to see that because people
don't really want to see like an animal
being dismembered i think that there
absolutely are people that are
not
unappetized by the experience of stu of
sustaining their food um going in and
getting their food bringing it back
being a part of the process totally i
think yeah but including the process of
the um i mean like my my example to this
is when i've and i think i've told you
this story before i just like when i was
going um spear fishing or
lobster diving for the first time
because that wasn't something growing up
in texas sure you could say you are
conditioned to kill animals but i had
never experienced um
i didn't grow in a hunting family or a
fishing family and my first time going
spear fishing was on a boat um obviously
but i was on a boat of just like hey go
do this and i went with the family and
um we went out there
we were spearfishing lobsters that was
my first experience as an adult not
having been conditioned to do that and i
found the experience of hunting for
lobster going
dismembering it getting it ready to cook
and cooking it one of the most enjoyable
experiences i've ever had i felt like i
had awoken
almost like a primal part of me that i
hadn't connected with before and so
that's where the conversations get
interesting because if you hear an
experience like that and you're like i
just don't understand how that's blocked
i don't think to me that's not hard to
understand for one i think that
maybe vegans are like what the heck are
you saying it's more like i'm trying to
put myself in your shoes like if you if
you feel like that is a good source of
sustenance for you and also fish are a
lot harder to relate to than like a cow
so like if you were to be like my first
time killing a cow and skinning it i
just doubt that you're gonna be like i
loved it like i just have a hard time
and also like my mom and even my
mother-in-law and just people i know who
have grown up on farms pretty much
everyone i've talked to will acknowledge
that like the first times that they've
seen it they were like sad to be like
they killed the family pig
like i love that pig like wait what
happened like like it's like a sad thing
for them to accept a reality that you
have to accept so it's not it's not i
don't think a nature thing i think it's
more nurture and you're right there are
certain people that are like
well i don't have a problem with at all
of course that's there but um i think
overall i i really think that the social
media example is a good example to be
like we don't want to show it people
don't want to see it it's not it's not
appetizing whereas like picking food
from a garden is appetizing and at least
beautiful to us you might not be like i
can't wait to munch on that raw kale but
you're still gonna find the process
beautiful sure that's just my point yeah
and to your point about um
like the hunting the fishing and the
conditioning
i don't know this will be interesting
for you here or not but in families that
i knew growing up who were hunting
families there was always one person in
the family that was like that's not my
thing i don't find that enjoyable they
were honest about it just like i don't
find that enjoyable however the older
brother was just like this is my
favorite hobby like this is this is what
i this is i feel like i was made to do
this for the family um and agreeing to
disagree there and then like the the you
know the other person is just like not
involved in the process now do i think
that that means that no one's supposed
to be involved in the process i don't
know i i actually really value that like
i value if someone is like i want
nothing to do with the hunting and the
skinning and the dismembering and and
creating that into food even if they
were
even if they were an animal
eater if they were like um i want
nothing to do with that i'd be like oh
yeah that makes that makes perfect sense
because i feel like we are all
different in the way in the same way
that um i think some people are
incredible nurses because they can
stomach the blood and like and stuff
like that and so and also i wanted to
say um
just to address the word stomaching i'm
using words that i'm because i'm in a
conversation with with a vegan if that
makes sense
um
and
i i think you made a really good point
what i would say to that is it wasn't
necessarily a word i would have used if
we weren't in this okay what would you
use if you weren't well i wouldn't have
i wouldn't have used um
stomaching as opposed to like i
understand that your perspective on that
i don't see it as i'm i don't see it
that way is what i'm saying i don't see
it as i'm stomaching
um
this experience i'm seeing it as
um a way to sustain food for myself i'm
seeing it as um primal and um you're
saying there's differences between maybe
like uh you know you think like it's
less gory i guess whenever it's like a
lobster or a fish um computer like a cow
or and less glory yes but also less
relatable like like if they don't have
like a cute like a nose and a face like
like a sweet animal face it's definitely
harder to relate to so like there's a
reason why children's books have books
about fishing but there's no children's
books about killing animals like other
animals sure right because fish are
really hard for people to relate to so
then the next question goes into okay so
even if we can't relate to these animals
even if people
are fine with doing it the question is
can we justify should we justify not
necessarily right or wrong
if it should be legal or not but our own
conscience should we justify doing it if
we don't have to if we if like okay
here's a question for you if
if you came to a conclusion and maybe
changed your mind that we don't need to
eat animals to be healthy would you
think that by
by the next step would be like well then
i shouldn't be supporting like
unnecessarily hurting an animal all
right yeah because i consider the
ethical hunting whatever you want to
call it or sustaining your food um
locally
um getting we haven't we didn't talk
about dairy but like uh how did we not
talk about very how is that possible
but i think that um
tell me your question again sorry that
if you did come to the conclusion that
you didn't need to eat animals to be
healthy and that you could be healthy
without them yes does that mean that you
should do that okay because that would
unnecessarily harm animals okay so and
because you'd ask me those those two
questions uh back to back earlier that i
wanted to address and that comes down to
um
not
producing unnecessary
death basically having purpose in death
um in the same way that you know uh a
deer dies when a lion goes and you know
kills a deer um and that is the food for
their uh what do you call it
you know yeah whatever whatever it's
called um their group
and uh anyways i think that in a
necessity like that that makes perfect
sense you wouldn't you wouldn't see that
as unkind but a lot of people watching
the videos when the anna when the lion
goes and attacks you're like what like
and you're like but they have to but
they have to and so in the conversation
of if we don't need
animal foods to be healthy then what
would be the point of of contributing to
their to their death and putting purpose
in their death that's why i like i don't
know if you've ever watched this
documentary um or read the book sacred
cow i've heard of it you've heard of it
um i'd love to hear your thoughts on it
another time but um i what i liked about
that documentary is it was a lot of um
former vegans who were involved in the
production in the writing and just like
understanding because they wanted to
relate to people who are because it's
the same
a lot of the same goals i guess ending
factory farming
regenerative farming is the goal and
they were just trying to relate to it
was like it was a documentary about
relatability i feel like um and in a lot
of the former vegans
uh mindsets they're like and they're
they're out there and going and being
the one that's killing the cow and
they're like they just see it as this
beautiful circle of life they see the
cow having purpose they stewarded that
lives that cow's life well while they
were alive and then it was something
that they honored as they as they
ate it so right because they feel they
need it to be healthy because they feel
it to be healthy so when you so in
answer to your question
if we
if i come to a conclusion one day if
globally we come to a conclusion one day
of like um animal foods are
a complete um you know
uh in necessity i don't know if that's
the right word but just like unnecessary
for our health um or even so that
they're downright harmful for us you
know like yeah what would be what would
what would be the point at all i've
never been a fan of um
hunting for sport that's never been
something that i've that i've supported
i've always just been like so that is
sound right yeah right so that means the
reason is because you think you need it
to be healthy exactly oh it comes back
always comes back like do we need it to
be healthy that's the question i think
the globally thing we can't really say
globally like there's so many different
types of situations and people in
in food insecurity like obviously that's
this is such a wider topic we can't just
say like everybody but we're talking
about everyone listening right now who
has a smartphone who has a computer who
has you know what i mean access to foods
like all kinds of whole foods that is
the question what it is for
um okay where do we go from there i mean
i guess i would ask then
because you think that there's a problem
with like sport hunting then
this goes back to the question i had
earlier which i don't think we ever
covered is that do you consider factory
farming to be
a problem simply for health reasons or
is there also animal ethical reasons
both i think i think definitely both um
there's and i know we didn't really talk
about uh dairy but there's i do want to
talk about it for a few minutes okay um
so like the lifelong separation from
baby to mother baby get something that's
not even like like real milk you know
it's like some powdered form um how how
animals are completely they're divorcing
um the animal from their natural state
and that
in return cycles into a whole slew of
soil issues because i am a huge fan of
regenerative farming where you re
marry i guess grazer to grassland and
through their
um
poop and their urine you are
re-mineralizing the earth and um
it's this whole symbiotic relationship
in return you can have more you know
nutrient-dense foods that come from that
but
anyways i think that it's a whole it's
everything um factory farming yeah i
stopped supporting factory farming i
think
six or seven years ago and it was
actually i mean it was definitely after
watching a a vegan
activism um documentary and that is what
i love about even the dairy industry
a lot of people watched some of these
documentaries and activism started from
that so even if we're not coming to the
same conclusion at the end of the day
that is what i love about the um how
we can still work together towards some
of the same goals depending on the
individual is what i mean and so um this
kind of coming back to more like ethical
dairy practices such as you know not
milking the cow more than once a day
when the baby is less than
six months old
um things like that and then obviously
uh
rearing baby and mom together
just simple things like that that were
changed were i believe one of the huge
parts of that was was vegan activism and
just like the waking up of like
we are not like this is not it this
ain't it you know factory farming is not
it right and all so like you it sounds
like then that you do have a problem
with like the abuse that happens on
factory farming definitely like the
picking up pigs and slamming them to the
ground baby pigs because they're they
don't want them anymore that's how
they're killing them and like the
dehorning and the the branding like but
that stuff is involved in even grass-fed
stuff like the cutting off tails into
horning so like is does that factor into
anything that yeah matters i think that
that's why it's completely 100
so important for if you are someone that
eats animal foods knowing your sourcing
go meet your farmer go meet the rancher
if you're doing something local
otherwise if you're doing something that
is imported um there is a group of
i don't know what you would call the i'm
afraid in the name of the organization
but it's a list of
um sourcing for grass-fed beef and organ
meats and whatnot and you can go
look at what kind of practices are done
at their at their ranches at their farms
and i think that was kind of the point
of you said you haven't watched sacred
cow no but i was planning on it but i
haven't yet okay that was that was kind
of the purpose of um
of the documentary is to create funding
to allow you know
these uh kinds of practices to happen
but also in a sustainable way where we
can like people can be fed so i think
that's that's kind of the
the hang up that a lot of like you know
plant-based or ethical vegan people have
is just like well how do you feed if you
know for example reducing the milk um
the milk production from from a cow
these are questions i'm i'm saying it
because i'm playing devil's advocate to
myself basically yeah they're really
there really is not it's not possible to
feed the world like that on the amount
of animal foods that people eat or the
amount of animal foods that the pro
metabolic way advises at least to what
i'm aware it could be wrong but based on
the way that i've seen correct me if i'm
wrong pro-metabolic weight is eating is
that like animal foods are significant
source of their calories and in order to
like feed the world like that like
there's no way that grass fed and the
whole like not milking the cow thing is
possible like sure it it lit they take
up so much land it would it's in pot
like it would not cover the earth like
we don't we don't have to possibly feed
the earth like that well i think that um
i think one of the good reasons just
what i was going to say is that like we
would have to significantly reduce our
intake of animal foods and and animal
foods would skyrocket the price of
animal foods
significantly priced like increase like
so that's one of the reasons why factory
farming started to happen you know and
if we're not going to subsidize animal
foods anymore than we already do which i
hope that we don't um people would have
to be paying like 20 30 a pound for
animal food sure and and then on top of
it though if we're still going to the
ethical aspect like
i feel like it's important question like
if we do have a problem with the
suffering the experience while they are
alive shouldn't we consider
going back to that let's say we can we
can let's say we call the conclusion
that you can
you can be healthy on veganism or eating
whole plant foods then
then
shouldn't we consider the killing of the
animal part of their suffering because
like we i think there's euphemisms used
to make us feel better about the foods
that we eat like
you know um it was ethically killed
ethically hunted and so i feel better
about the foods that i'm eating but we
would never say that we like ethically
killed like anyone other than an animal
it just feels better
when really that animal didn't want to
die sure you know what i'm saying i
think that we say these things
now because of the of the pushback from
from vegan activists who are like well
this isn't ethical and we're like well
how do we find a solution where there
there is a you know massive group of
people that absolutely believe that they
need that food in their lives
and that's the word question exactly yes
and
i and that's really where you have to
come down to it because i mean i can't
honestly blame someone if they really
believe that they need those foods to be
healthy right and so that's where the
questions and the these types of
conversations and the listening to
different experts and like really trying
to figure out figure that answer out is
i think the most helpful because if we
don't need them then we can actually
move forward but if you actually do need
them like can you really can you can't
blame someone for what you really need
but i do think that like the ethical
the ethical component of like killing an
animal like they could grow up on like
the nicest grassy field but they're
going to end up at the same
slaughterhouse and like slaughterhouses
like literally there's this document
called dominion i don't know i've
watched it yeah you have watched it yeah
um it's not even about factory farming
right it's just slaughterhouses right so
like it's from all different types of
farming and it's it's gruesome and it's
not it's not nice it's not kind and it's
like
this is not to say you're not kind it's
to say that like the process of what
these animals go through whether they
had the label grass-fed humane whatever
yeah like they still end up in the same
slaughterhouse where everyone around
them is being killed and all the blood
and like that there's fear and pain and
there's no painful there's no pain like
pain-free way to do it this i think it's
like kind of a
it's a lie
well and what it comes down to always is
is the question that you're asking is if
we need animal foods or not because we
would never call
like the example i gave earlier you know
a lion killing a deer any other animal
killing any other animal for their food
it is gruesome it's bloody it's crazy
and um
we don't see that as unkind and so it
comes back to
the
definition of okay well what is how do
we know what right and wrong is and i
think that's what um
i guess like the conversations that come
from there i'm just always so interested
to hear like hey like where do you find
your definition of right and wrong and
like
um and how do you know that and how do
you know to be true right things like
that yeah and i feel like the question
of writing wrong could be an entire
podcast episode on it sort of like a
whole two-hour conversation like what's
going wrong but that's why it comes down
to what's like not supporting
unnecessary heart like yeah necessary
suffering so that's where we part rows
it's like do we need it do we not and
that and that's like do we need them to
be healthy or not and that's where the
difference is and that's why i think
it's so important for anyone listening
who is vegan who is an ethical vegan to
not be like quick to judge someone who
is advocating for a different way that
i'm not talking about someone who's just
like mindlessly not thinking about the
foods they're eating and also you might
have been there once too right like us
even before we were the way that we are
we might have mindlessly ate in a way
nothing definitely right but even
someone who is advocating for a certain
way to understand their perspective is
huge and super important so okay let's
just quickly get into dairy what do you
think are the ethics like is there an
ethical way to do dairy in your mind
well i guess my
opinion of what could be ethical would
bring us back to
what things look like before factory
farming and dairy was more expensive
dairy was this we've talked about this
before it was a this delicacy you know
um and you know you got it from like
royalty and like only they had access to
it because of the you know the
what they could have accessed from the
cow the livestocks and the cows around
them and the goats i mean cheap like
there's a there's a lot of different um
animals that you can get you can get
dairy from
um if i had to prefer one it out it
would actually be ca or excuse me goats
and not and not cows um but as far as
the ethics in my mind of my opinion of
what would be done in an ethical way is
to
create the most natural environment for
the cow and the calf
in a way that stewards their bodies well
and so not using
antibiotics and um
well i won't say that word but like
other things you can inject into them um
and hormones of course like not adding
hormones into into the cow allowing the
cow and the calf to um
to rear together and then
different practices have have have
different like rules on this there's one
that's i think it's f-a-c-t which is
like a list of all the ethical dairy
companies that do this but some don't
milk their cows more than twice a day
and then some don't milk their cows more
than once a day where we access our raw
milk it's not more than once a day um
and
it is more
art well this is also island living as
well so there's like one
one spot where you go and you get your
your milk from but
absolutely we have to think about the
question of just like okay well what
does that do to the price i would also
like to see what would happen if we had
we've had 100 plus years of government
funds to
support like mono cropping and tilling
and
you know the the cheap production of of
the food that we have today and i would
like to see what would happen if we
as a country or um globally try to
try to reverse that i guess and go back
to more um in a way that restores not
only obviously like the grazer to the
grassland but restores our health as
well because you're actually treating
the soil well and not trying to fight
over like in the livestock's not trying
to fight over the same grass
um did i answer your question yeah that
did okay yeah um
i
i feel like the unders i mean let me
know your thoughts on this the
understanding the fundamental components
is that
cow's milk is for a baby cow
goat's milk is for a baby goat like
human milk is for baby humans like does
that at all factor into your decision on
if it's a health food or not um well i
think that that's why dairy has been so
studied and i think that we would find
conflicting opinions on like is very bad
for your hormones is it good for your
hormones i know that the dairy the
hormones that are in dairy our bodies
produce 6000 times more than what you'd
find in a glass of milk and so the
impact on our hormones just because it's
coming from a cow
or a goat
is is questionable if if you're drinking
even if you're drinking like a gallon of
it today or excuse me a day um as far as
it being unnatural just because it is
from a cow i think we can use that same
logic on a lot of things and that's
where we're just going to be kind of
like cycling
well because if we're really going to
use argument like our biology getting
back to our biology like i mean can
it's clear that like cow's milk is for a
baby cow like that i feel like that's
not that hard like i feel like it would
be really hard to refute that sure like
desi every mammal on the planet they
make milk for their babies like sure and
after we're waiting for our mothers we
don't need it ever again and the only
reason that we've had adapted to where
like maybe 30 percent of people still
have the lactase enzymes people digest
it is because
we have over time used cows to be able
to sustain ourselves as we travel across
civilizations to make sure we have
a significant calorie source as we
settle in new places where we don't know
what the food's going to be like right
and over time because we have included
in our diet that's why we've had that
like adaptation but oh sorry but really
quick though i want you to answer this
but i also realized that i never
addressed what you said about the
ethical parts of dairy
like your idea of what could be the
possibility like is just not possible on
a global scale like for the especially
for the amount of dairy that people eat
if you're just really talking like a
gallon of milk a day like there's no way
that we could feed
people that much milk even even like two
cups a day that much milk the entire
world on that type of farming it's just
not possible especially sorry sorry no
well what would be your what would be
your solution to that my solution is
that we don't need to be eating dairy so
if if i'm just trying to merge here but
like if people reduce the amount of
dairy that they were eating if dairy
wasn't going into
absolute junk processed food right like
any like
cheez-its you know just like if it
wasn't going and being sold in this mass
production way and therefore we're not
even like a lot of people are eating
things and not even knowing that there's
dairy in it absolutely and so um i guess
if we merge the solutions of lowering
the
mindless dairy consumption um you know
what would that look like if we invested
our you know money tax dollars into
something that could get us a more
ethical um
way of doing it i guess right well i
think that it's all about supply and
demand and education is key and so
that's why we're having conversations
like this and that's why i have like my
podcast that's why i do what i do and
why you do what you do for obviously you
have your own opinions on why um but
over time if people start eating less
and less dairy and less foods with dairy
in it the demand would shift and people
would they would start making products
that didn't have dairy in it and we
would start having a higher demand for
whole plant foods hopefully if more
people start eating more whole plant
foods and that's where the supply the
demand supply and demand happens and
also because we we i hope that our tax
dollars wouldn't actually support and
fund more types of farmings like that
because it isn't sustainable for us
because vegans i don't know if you know
this but they they require far less land
than animal food eaters like one what is
it like 1 16 of the land a vegan and a
vegan oh sorry 1 8 i feel like i wrote
it down um vegans only re require like
one sixth of an acre per year per person
whereas not an animal food eater
requires eight times that amount and
that doesn't even take into account if
you were doing all grass-fed where it
would make even more land so we simply
on a number scale don't have the
possibility to feed the world in this
idyllic like idyllic way that maybe
like sounds better but and then on top
of it though could we consider that
knowing that that's true that we could
consider maybe we don't need to be
needing eating as much of it so maybe
you don't agree with me that we don't
need dairy in our diets but maybe we
don't need to be eating near as much as
we put it in does that make sense that
makes perfect sense i think um
with the land thing because that
obviously opens up and again i'm not an
expert on regenerative farming what i
can pull from is watching
organizations that i really enjoy
learning from the savory institute is
one of them and to this i just think of
the example of what they did with the um
maasai
in kenya so like livestock
everywhere everyone's fighting over the
grassland like i was saying earlier
and what they did first off in the soil
was
severely uh depleting and getting
unhealthier and unhealthier and
unhealthier and what happened as a
result of that is wildlife you know
wasn't coming back and and hanging out
in this lush because actually the rivers
weren't even really flowing anymore and
so
this is ecotourism
okay
um and so ecotourism goes down the
health the funds and then the prosperity
of the entire village is going down so
something that savery institute did is
okay like let's restore
community let's take all the livestock
that are all separated let's put them
into one concentrated place and then
practice um
communal grazing patterns and so
allowing the grass to rest allowing the
grosser wrist allowing the grass to rest
to mimic predator uh hurting basically
this is like
101 regenerative farming and i'm
probably not
explaining it well but essentially
allowing the grass to to rest getting
the livestock in one place allowing them
to fertilize the grass in that place it
restored the health of the soil
tremendously rivers started flowing
wildlife returned then the food is more
nutrient dense so not only are they
not okay
not only are they i'm freezing this
wrong but essentially the food that
they're eating they need less of because
it's more nutrient dense if that makes
sense um do you think though because
from what i understand that if they're
eating grass it takes far
about grass
right yes yeah if you're going to feed
them that then they take so much more
time to get them to uh to a weight to be
able to slaughter them so it takes more
energy more resources more land to get
them to that weight as opposed to doing
like factory farm grain so
i have we talked about like do you think
that i support grain fed cattle no okay
okay okay yeah what i'm saying is that
as much as those things sound idyllic
they're just not possible on the scale
that we're talking about on how much
meat that is promoted and animal foods
that is promoted sure for the whole
world and then on top of it
i didn't want to cut you off but i was
going to say something about
regenerative grazing so once you finish
and then i'll say oh and um and like all
like everything that you're bringing up
i'm i'm like yeah these are great
questions like let's let me definitely
look into these things um because like i
said i'm not an expert on these but
essentially with the
um with their practices in mind it's
essentially how do we lose how do we use
uh less land restore the health of the
land therefore like the messiah i just
think of this because it was the coolest
example of when the wildlife returned
because the health of the land risk
return they were able to open back up
ecotourism and then the funds were going
back into the villages restoring the
prosper prosperity and of health of the
of them as a whole and i just thought it
was such a beautiful example of
of just not divorcing the of the of the
grazer to the grassland and allowing
that to happen can i ask you a question
like a follow-up question on that okay
so when you say that vegans or
plant-based diet only needs a certain um
smaller amount of land amount of land
what is that i guess like
referring to like what has grown on that
land it's talking comparing it to
everything that is eaten within a year
compared to how much land is required
for animal foods because for animal
foods you also need to take into account
the land that it takes to grow the grain
that most of the cows are eating versus
or grass-fed that requires even more
land because they have to eat so much
grass to get to become a big big cow to
be able to be slaughtered to feed people
so that it requires so much land that if
we're really talking about we're wilding
the best thing to do is eat more plants
and less animal foods because it
requires so much less land and then we
can let more areas thrive and rewild
that's really like a better way to a
wild because and like take the amazon
forest for instance like 91 of amazon
destruction comes from animal
agriculture and they'll say well what
about soy well most of that soy is going
towards animal feed for sure so i agree
if you were to really instead if you're
going to try to do that grass fed for
cows it would be the same thing would
take up even more land so if we're
really going to consider it the best way
to wild
our nature we would be eating more
plants and less animal foods because it
takes up significantly less less land
because we filter up to we like lose
upwards of 60 of the calories by
filtering plants through animals first
then we do just to eat directly just
directly eating plants so i guess of
that i wonder like what even the
solution would be as far as the land and
the soil knowing that from my
understanding regenerative farming
practices are kind of our best bet as
far as restoring
top soil i agree i do think that like
regenerative farming is arguably better
for the soil but when it i actually
wanted to bring up something there's a
really the largest meta-analysis like
looking at animal grazing um and it was
called grazed and confused by the food
climate research network found that
despite anecdotal claims it's still very
much a net co2 emitting practice
even though specific forms of grazing
can help sequester co2 in the oil like
the soil like the white oak pastures yes
exactly like even their own studies show
that they were still net neck um
commissioned commissioning from that um
anyway so that that was my main point of
that i do think that it obviously is
better for the soil than everything
we're doing with mono cropping and corn
and soy so like we're so on the same
page there i think the best way for us
to find common ground maybe would be if
we're really going to talk about
planetary health and also we could even
consider
if you're really talking about like past
our ancestors right and how they ate
because that's a lot of how you consider
how to eat right is our ancestors before
the processed food industry um before
all the affluents like we really didn't
eat so much animal food so if we could
consider the planetary aspect and the
well like the the kindness to the
animals to at least cause less harm if
you really believe that we need animals
to eat maybe we don't need as much as we
think we do and as a result we're going
to help the planet and to just eat more
plants that way
and do you consider yeah and i and i
wonder
in that do you feel like it is the
i guess the amount of people that is is
the problem well plus everything else
that comes with that but like um do you
feel like we're at a place where we're
at now because of
the population yeah well i mean that's
part of it but the other part is just
the way we've gotten so far away from
nature we don't live in the way that our
ancestors lived and the way our
ancestors lived back before the
processed food industry and grocery
stores we were not eating the amount of
animal foods that people are eating
today so it's really easy to be like oh
i'm gonna eat a lot of dairy i'm gonna
eat a lot of this and i'm just gonna
stop at my you know farm for the dairy
but then everything else i get might be
at the grocery store
not taking into account of like if
you're really growing your own like
raising your own animals and growing
your own food like the majority of food
is coming from plants and then the the
meat is like the once a week type of
thing and so considering that we could
at least be like maybe we don't need as
much as we think
um but obviously i'm still arguing for
that we don't need it at all to be
healthy if we eat a whole plant foods
based diet and that's not to say that
there's going to be 100 health 100 at
the time because i don't think anybody
experiences that i think that's kind of
like a
frustrating thing that you and i have
talked about you know my feelings about
that how people have sometimes will be
like well this person had this
experience when they were plant-based
and i think there's kind of an unfair
comparison that like if you're not vegan
and you experience an element it's
really rare that people are like it's
because you're eating animals whereas if
you're vegan and you experience an
ailment it's like it must be because
you're not eating it so that's obviously
a totally different conversation but i
love that you
like empathize with my frustrations
yeah she just put it in my shoes and she
was just like um if someone was
following your way of eating it's not a
diet it's more of like a lifestyle shift
and figure out what works best for you
but if someone took it as a diet and was
like i tried what you ate didn't work
for me so i went back to this
keto or something made me feel all these
terrible things yeah i started
deteriorating like that would be really
frustrating for you totally i would i
would definitely feel a need to
um
to i would be defensive and just like
okay well that's not really and i think
why that is and ellen and i are bonded
over this is because what's most
important to us and
um kind of the basis of the whole
conversation is well what is the truth
what is the truth and like we don't want
someone to misunderstand
um what we're saying and uh and twist it
and like project it as something else
and we're like whoa like you
misunderstood the whole the whole point
so easy to do that's why it's vulnerable
to be to be here it is oh my gosh this
has been such a good conversation though
i think we're doing a pretty good job
like rounding out the conversation
coming to a conclusion i think a good
way to end would be for each of us to
just kind of make a statement on like
our overall reasons why we think the way
we do and just kind of end it based on
the conversation do you like that idea
yeah okay so i'll go first and then you
can finish um
i feel like based on the planetary
aspects the ethical reasons as well as i
think the overwhelming body of evidence
that we can eat a plant-predominant or
plant-exclusive diet to be healthy
shows me why that to me that's good
reason why i do live the way i do the
lifestyle that i do i think
understanding that like um
animal agriculture is the leading cause
of ocean dead zones um the amount of
animal poop manure that comes from
animals in the waste run off into our
oceans and lakes
species extinction extinction water
pollution habitat destruction all that
taking into account plus the fact that
my
inclination is to
um cause the least amount of harm that
is reasonable reasonably possible
especially knowing that i can be healthy
on eating whole plant foods and eating a
plant-based diet for myself to me that
is why i live a vegan lifestyle
because i do think that the overwhelming
body of evidence is that
that we should be eating a predominant
amount of our calories from whole plant
foods
um
and that could mean that means like at
least 85 percent of our calories have
been plants and that could be a whole
other discussion together we could even
do a whole conversation on just that
topic of like how much right and and i
feel like that evidence there to me is
it is the reason why i live the way they
do plus the fact that i've been you know
living vegan and thriving and raising my
healthy four children um having four
wonderfully healthy vegan pregnancies um
is a testament of why i live the way
that i do so that's my rounding
discussion i love that um
i i'm trying to think of how to like
summarize this all in one thought but
essentially like i think that people
that try to eat um animal foods in an
ethical or conscious way again
just using these words um
have a lot of the same goals as as
vegans and ethical vegans maybe not
necessarily
all of the same health goals but like
being healthy absolutely and we all have
different definitions of what what
healthy means um
i think having conversations like this
is
so incredibly important so incredibly
important so we can get out of our echo
chamber chamber realize oh there might
be a problem with this that i haven't
thought about before where do we go from
here yes where can i learn more
information about this um and i think
that the goal of myself is of course
nourishing the body that
in a way that i understand
how the body thrives and at the at the
place that i'm at in my life um that is
incorporating you know uh organ meats
and um shellfish and
different types of
red meats and i think that and eggs of
course but like
i mean the list could go on and on as
far as the things that we do
agree on like we covered in the
beginning of the episode um and so that
is the beautiful thing of just like hey
like we're all on this journey of trying
to figure out what how how to thrive um
and then how to feed our family in the
best way possible
this is always like a very um touching
subject i think for moms too because
they're like i want to do it right i
want to thank
my kids right um and i think at the end
of the day how can we get back to
sustainable practices and you brought up
a lot of great points today that i
um i'm just excited to learn more about
um like i said the i think that the the
movement that has come from the people
that created sacred cow is one of the
one of the major ones i lean on as far
as
information but i want to broaden my
horizons as far as as far as information
and
like i said that's just why i think it's
so important to
to have these kinds of conversations
that i really hope you guys
you guys are encouraged to just see i
guess the the fruit of what can come
from having opposing
you know conversations um opposing
viewpoint conversations because a lot of
us have the exact same goals at the end
of the day
i'm so glad that you brought that up
honestly i am 100 agree with you about
that
the importance of having conversations
with people who disagree with you to
help understand why people think the way
that they do is helpful for your own
growth and mindset and helpful in your
relationships and i can honestly say
you're becoming one of my best friends
and i'm so thankful for you and your
family and my life our children i don't
know if you know our best friends
koa and scout are smitten with each
other
obsessed with their friendship like
honestly it's the most beautiful thing
and i'm so thankful to get to know you
and your family we love you so much i'm
like about to cry oh my gosh
you guys have no idea how like mutual
the love is i mean the fact that i that
ellen was at my birth shows you like how
intimate our friendship is and so the
the idea that
you can have like a thriving
relationship and friendship with
somebody who doesn't see eye to eye eye
on you on everything is is it's just a
really important i feel like life
realization to have
how to actually do it that's something
to navigate through for people that it's
harder for them to have these these kind
of conversations but i just appreciate
you so much and i just really appreciate
you uh
like inviting this conversation to
happen yes i appreciate you too i think
this is the perfect way to end it thank
you corey for being here
[Music]